I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Welcome to Office Ladies, everyone. Hello. Hi. Good morning or good afternoon. Or maybe good evening. We don't know when you listen. No. So we're going to cover all of it. What if I was like, actually, we do? What? We are here today to talk about local ad, season four, episode nine, which I'm going to declare a hidden gem. Whenever you say I'm going to declare,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。欢迎来到《办公室女郎》，大家好。你好。嗨。早上好或下午好。或者也许晚上好。我们不知道你什么时候听。不。所以我们要讲到方方面面。如果我说，其实，我知道呢？什么？我们今天在这里讨论第四季第九集《地方广告》，我愿称之为一颗被埋没的宝珠。每当你说是我要宣称，
you know where my brain goes. I can't help it. Bankruptcy? Yes. For the rest of my life, I'm just going to walk this earth and someone's going to be like, I declare and I'm going to think bankruptcy. Yeah. You can't help it. It's like that's what she said. We can't help it. That's what she said. I don't know. It doesn't work. It is a gem. Let's hear about it, Jenna. It was written by BJ Novak and directed by Jason Reitman. Here is a summary. When the Scranton branch is asked to participate in a Dunder Mifflin television ad, Michael seizes his chance to exhibit his creativity and enlists the help and talents of his employees. I mean, has Michael ever had a more exciting day at work? No. I can't imagine the giddiness
你知道我的大脑会飘到哪去。我控制不住。破产？是的。在我的余生中，我将在这世上漫步，然后有人会说，我宣布，而我会想到破产。是啊。你控制不住。就像那是她说的。我们控制不住。那是她说的。我不知道。这行不通。它确实是一颗宝珠。听听是怎么回事吧，珍娜。它由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，杰森·雷特曼执导。以下是剧情梗概。当斯克兰顿分公司被邀请参与邓德·米夫林电视台广告时，迈克尔抓住了展示自己创造力的机会，并征求了员工们的帮助和才华。我的意思是，迈克尔有过比这更令人兴奋的工作日吗？没有。我无法想象那种兴奋劲儿
that he had, how he woke up to his bacon on his George Foreman grill by his bed. He ate it real fast, nudged Jan because shoes passed out and went to work. He is on fire today. Also in this episode, Dwight explores the online world of second life as a means of escaping his real life pain about his breakup with Angela. And Andy will not stop asking Dwight's advice in his pursuit of Angela. It's just torturing poor Dwight. It is. Have you ever had a crush where your friend was maybe liking the same guy but was doing better or something? And they'd be like, hey, he said this, what should I say back? And you're just like, oh, it's the worst. It is poor, poor Dwight.
他有多高兴，他是怎么伴着床边乔治·福尔曼烤盘上的培根醒来的。他飞快地吃完，推了推晕过去的简然后去上班。他今天状态好极了。此外在本集中，德怀特探索了第二人生的网络世界，以此来逃避他与安吉拉分手带来的现实生活中的痛苦。而安迪在追求安吉拉时，会不断征求德怀特的意见。这简直是在折磨可怜的德怀特。确实是。你有没有过这样的经历：你的朋友可能喜欢同一个男生，但进展更顺利或者别的什么？然后他们会说，嘿，他说了这个，我该怎么回？而你心里就会想，哦，这简直糟透了。确实是可怜的德怀特。
Well, let's get into some fast facts. Fast fact number one, like I said, this episode is directed by Jason Reitman. Jason Reitman, Golden Globe nominated for his movie, Thank You for Smoking. He also won the Independent Spirit Award for best screenplay for that and Academy Award nominated director of Juno, among many other things. I mean, amazing. Yeah. Now when he came to direct the office, he had finished Juno, but it had not come out yet. So all of those accolades were in his future. But one of the stars of Juno was Rainn Wilson. Yes. A little connection. And Jenna, I'm not let you do your fast facts, but this whole episode for me is about crossover connections with people. Oh, local ad colon
好吧，让我们进入一些快讯。快讯一，正如我所说，这一集由杰森·雷特曼执导。杰森·雷特曼，因电影《感谢吸烟》获得金球奖提名。他还凭此片获得了独立精神奖最佳剧本，并且是奥斯卡最佳导演提名者，执导过《朱诺》等诸多作品。我的意思是，太棒了。是的。当他来执导《办公室》时，他已经完成了《朱诺》，但该片尚未上映。所以所有这些荣誉都在他的未来。但《朱诺》的主演之一是雷恩·威尔森。是的。一个小小的连结。珍娜，我不会让你去播报你的快讯，但对我来说，这一整集都是关于人们之间的交叉连结。哦，地方广告冒号
crossover connections. Local ad colon hidden Jim slash crossover connections. There it is. Hashtag. That's what she said. That's what she said. Jenna, I have been emailing with Jason over these last few months because Oscar and Brian and I were part of Jason's remake of the Princess Bride for Quibi. It was so good. It was so fun. And we all shot it, you know, separately, like at our homes. And then Jason added together all the dialogue. I played Vasini, Oscar played Inigo and Brian played Fessick. It was so much fun. So we were trading emails and I was like, Hey, by the way, local ad is coming up. We just send in some audio clips and he was so generous. These are so great. I'm excited for you guys
交叉连结。地方广告冒号隐藏宝珠斜杠交叉连结。这不就来了。话题标签。那是她说的。那是她说的。珍娜，这几个月我一直在和杰森发邮件，因为奥斯卡、布莱恩和我参与了杰森为Quibi重制的《公主新娘》。太棒了。太好玩了。我们都是（你知道的）分开拍摄的，比如在各自家里。然后杰森把所有的对白剪辑在了一起。我扮演维齐尼，奥斯卡扮演伊尼戈，布莱恩扮演费西克。太好玩了。所以我们一直在交换邮件，我说，嘿，顺便说一句，《地方广告》快播出了。我们刚发了一些音频片段过去，他真是太慷慨了。这些真的太棒了。我为你俩感到兴奋
to hear him. Of course, the first thing we asked him was how he came to direct on the office. And here is what he had to say. Like any human being who was alive at the time, I was an enormous fan of the office. I decided it was the greatest thing on television. It was this collection of the greatest talent actors and writers who were making a generation defining comedy, which was somehow sweet, but always subversive. And the storytelling was great. You know, feature directors that I really admired had already come and directed the show like Harold Ramis. I think I had already directed Rain in Juneau. And I had these little connections to other people on the show. I feel like I knew a fair amount
能听到他的声音。当然，我们问他的第一件事他是如何来执导《办公室》的。以下是他的言论。就像当时活着的任何人类一样，我是《办公室》的超级粉丝。我认定这是电视上最伟大的节目。这是一群最伟大的天才演员和编剧，他们正在制作一部定义了一代人的喜剧，它不知为何很温馨，但总是具有颠覆性。而且叙事棒极了。你知道的，我真正崇拜的剧情片导演已经来执导过这部剧了，比如哈罗德·雷米斯。我想我已经导演过雷恩的《朱诺》了。我对剧中其他人也有这些小小的连结。我觉得我对
of the cast and some writers on the show already. I don't even know why. But either my agent reached out and said, Hey, do you want to direct any television? And I think my response was, I would be up for directing the office. And Rain made it even sound like a better opportunity by saying, look, the worst you can do when you direct the office is get a B plus and the best you can do is an A. All right. I mean, I always used to tell people that directing the office was like someone asking you, do you want to drive my Lamborghini? And say, okay, it's just a, it was a show. And clearly, particularly when I came in, because I came in, in season four, it's so clearly knew exactly who it
剧组的演员和一些编剧已经相当了解了。我甚至不知道为什么。但要么是我的经纪人联系我说，嘿，你想导演任何电视剧吗？我想我的回应是，我愿意导演《办公室》。而雷恩让这听起来像是一个更好的机会，他说，听着，当你导演《办公室》时，最差能得个B加，最好能得个A。好吧。我的意思是，我过去常对别人说，导演《办公室》就像有人问你，你想开我的兰博基尼吗？然后说，好吧，这只是一部剧。显然，特别是当我加入的时候，因为我是第四季加入的，它非常清楚自己是谁以及它是如何制作的，所以作为一名导演，实际上你只是第一位观众，你有机会也许，你知道的，把几个人引向正确的方向。但除此之外，作为《办公室》的导演，这是一次学习经历，也是一次快乐的经历。一个音频片段的隐藏宝珠，杰森和交叉连结怎么样？是的。全都在这了。我喜欢他说的导演《办公室》就像如果你朋友说，嘿，你想开我的兰博基尼吗？太好了。我们还问杰森，他对在片场和我们所有人在一起有什么第一印象。
was and how it was made that as a director, really you are simply the first audience and you have the opportunity to maybe, you know, point a couple of people in the right direction. But otherwise, as a director on the office, it's a learning experience and a joyful one. How about a hidden gem of an audio clip, Jason and crossover connections? Yes. It's all there. I love what he said about directing the office was like, if your friend said, Hey, do you want to drive my Lamborghini? Like so nice. We also asked Jason if he had any first impressions of, you know, being on the set and being with all of us. I remember getting there and I was just blown away by the directing process that the camera operators were meant to be
我记得到达那里时，我被摄像机操作员本身就是表演者的导演过程震撼了。这与我过去导演过的任何东西都不同，我拿到了一份平面图，并被要求画出摄像机操作员的表演，他们会朝哪个方向走，会看哪个方向，因为这个想法是，在一次长镜头拍摄中，你应该能够涵盖场景剪辑中可以使用的每一个摄像机角度。所以这作为一名导演是一个独特的挑战，也是一个令人兴奋的挑战，你知道有八个镜头。你想拍出一个广角、几个中景、特写，并且能够摇摄到反应。而且不知何故，你有两个摄像机，两个操作员，他们需要捕捉所有这些东西，同时又不能拍到
performers themselves. And unlike anything I'd ever directed in the past, I was given a floor plan and asked to draw out the performance of the camera operators, which direction they would go and which direction they would look because the idea was that within a single take, you should be able to cover every camera angle that can be used in the editing of a scene. So this was a unique challenge as a director and kind of a thrilling one where you knew that there was eight shots. You wanted to get off a wide, a couple mediums closeups and you want to be able to pan into reactions. And that somehow you had two cameras, you had two operators and they were going to need to catch all these things without catching
彼此。当一个人从另一个人身边经过时，他们会躲在桌子底下。这就像在玩数独。这就像一个有趣的难题要解决。与此同时，看那些知道怎么做的真正操作员也是一种刺激。我记得片场冷得要命，如果我没记错的话，这是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔要求的，整个寒冷，这个喜剧的事情。我喜欢这个。我喜欢冷。所以这对我来说没问题。好的。关于那个音频片段，我想说的是：他提到的两件事，一是对摄像工作的不可思议、大师级的编排，二是冷得要命。这应该能告诉你我们的片场有多冷。
each other. And they would duck under desks as one would hand by the other. It was like doing Sudoku. It was like this fun problem to solve. And at the same time, a thrill to watch the actual operators who knew how to do it. I remember the set was freezing cold, which was Steve Carell's request, if I remember right, this whole cold, this comedy thing. I love that. I love cold. So that was fine by me. Okay. Here's what I have to say about that audio clip. The two things that he mentions are one just incredible, masterful choreography of the camera work and that it was freezing cold. That should tell you how cold our set was.
我的意思是，我有那些不在场景中的人的照片，比如发型师、化妆师，穿着带兜帽的厚风衣，戴着手套。但我真的很高兴杰森描述了我们摄像师跳的那种舞。我的意思是，我们已经讨论过一点了，但我认为他在描述时非常雄辩。因为看那些家伙真的是一件迷人、美丽的事情。如果你不在场景中，你可以看着那些家伙，我总是印象深刻。我想第一次走进我们的片场，看到他们为拍摄所做的一切，肯定特别奇妙。
I mean, I have pictures of people that weren't in scenes like hair and makeup and full on parkas with hoods up and gloves. But I am really glad that Jason described the sort of dance that our cameraman did. I mean, we've talked about it a little bit, but I thought he was very eloquent in how he described it. Cause it was a really just fascinating, beautiful thing to watch. If you weren't in the scene and you could watch those guys and I was like always so impressed. And I imagine especially weird to see the first time walking onto our set and seeing all that they did to get the shot.
是的。我关于杰森的记忆之一是，我们在拍“访谈特写”时他笑场了。我只记得他笑得前俯后仰，因为我在这集里有一个，删除片段里也有一些没被剪进去的。所以他那天一定拍了一整天的访谈特写，他在DVD评论音轨里谈到，作为这部剧的导演，他真正没有做好准备的一件事是导演如何成为演员阵容的一部分，因为当你做访谈特写时，导演坐在会议室里，我们直接和导演对话。是的。作为伪纪录片的一部分，他说他一直笑，这也是我的记忆。是的。你说的太对了。等我们讲到那里时再谈，但帕姆有一个访谈特写
Yeah. One of the things I remember about Jason is him breaking and laughing when we did talking heads. I just remember him cracking up cause I had one in this and there were also some in the deleted scenes that didn't make it in. So he must have had a whole day of talking heads and he talked about it in the DVD commentary that one of the things he wasn't really prepared for as a director on this show is how the director is part of the cast because the director sits in the conference room when you do talking heads and we talk directly to the director. Yes. As part of the mockumentary and he said he kept laughing and that is my memory too. Yes. You're so right. We'll talk about it when we get to it, but Pam has a talking head
我们怎么也拍不下去。好吧，我们非常感谢杰森发来这些片段，我们还有更多。我们会在整集节目中穿插播放。是的。接下来是快讯二，全部关于“第二人生”。哦，珍娜，我跟你讲，当我重温这一集并看到“第二人生”的剧情线时，我就想，哦，我知道我的好闺蜜珍娜·费舍一定会对此进行深度剖析，因为你喜欢这种游戏。你玩这种游戏。
that we could not get through. Well we're really grateful that Jason sent in these clips and we have even more. We'll sprinkle them throughout the episode. Yes. Next up is VastFact number two, which is all about second life. Oh, Jenna, let me tell you, when I rewatched this and saw the second life storyline, I was like, oh, I know my lady, Jenna Fisher, is going to do a deep dive on this because you love these kind of games. You play these kind of games.
嗯，我玩《模拟人生》，这和“第二人生”很不一样。哦，顺便说一句，“第二人生”是真实的，今天它依然存在。就像德怀特在剧中所说，这不是一个游戏。《模拟人生》是一个游戏，你有一个角色，你必须吃东西、上厕所、找工作、试图建造豪宅等等。这就是我所记得的，珍娜。我记得你建了整个世界。你在经营你的世界。那不就像“第二人生”吗？有点像。你知道的，当我给自己建了一只小房子，还有一只像我真正的猫安迪的小猫时，我就不玩《模拟人生》了。在游戏中，我在
Well, I played The Sims, which is very different from second life. Oh, by the way, second life is real and it still exists today. And like Dwight says in the episode, it's not a game. Sims is a game where you have a character and you have to eat food and go to the bathroom and have a job and try to build a mansion and things like that. This is what I remember, Jenna. I remember you built a whole world. You are working on your world. Isn't that like a second life? A little bit. You know, I stopped playing Sims when I had built myself a little house and I had a little cat that was just like my real cat, Andy. And in the game, I was
抚摸我的假猫，我看了看我真正的猫，它一副……的表情，我想，是的，我需要退出这个游戏去抚摸我的真正的猫。哦，天哪。所以“第二人生”，它早于推特、Instagram和社交媒体。它几乎就像一个虚拟的在线聊天室。你创建了自己的化身，然后你可以进去与别人的化身互动。就像Reddit一样，就好像我把自己做成动画，然后我可以进入Reddit聊天室。是的，非常相似。但你可以建造东西。你可以建造一个小旅馆并经营它
petting my fake cat and I looked over at my real cat who was like, and I thought, yeah, I need to get out of this game and pet my real cat. Oh, man. So second life, it predated Twitter and Instagram and social media. And it was almost like a virtual online chat room. You created an avatar of yourself and then you could go in and interact with other people's avatars. Like Reddit, like if I animated myself and then I could go in a Reddit chat room. Yes, very similar. But you can build things. You could build a little hotel and run it
然后其他化身可以来到你的旅馆。哦，这挺有趣的。你可以去听音乐会。还有大学课程、新闻发布会，你可以以你的化身身份出席。你甚至可以买地、买衣服和电子产品、拜访朋友。这是一个在线世界。它由Linden Lab创建，它就像是一个社交体验。这不是游戏。你不会赢得任何东西，但你可以在游戏中赚钱，然后你可以把钱花在这些不同的体验上。我懂了。我能看出这会非常有趣。这让我想起一点
and then other avatars could come to your hotel. Oh, that's kind of fun. You can go to a concert. There were college classes, press conferences that you could attend as your avatar. And you could even buy land, shop for clothes and gadgets, visit with friends. It was this online world. It was created by Linden Lab and it was just like a social experience. It wasn't a game. You didn't win anything, but you could earn money in the game that you would then spend on these different experiences. I get it. I could see where that would be really fun. It kind of reminds me a little
我们刚刚和孩子们一起看的电影叫《头号玩家》。你大致设计你的化身，然后你可以去探索并与其他的人互动。我没看过那部电影，但听起来很切中要害。你应该看看。好的。我想你会喜欢的。好的。我会看前20分钟的。
bit of this movie we just watched with the kids called Ready Player One. You sort of design your avatar and you get to go explore and interact with other people. I've not seen that movie, but that sounds on point. You should see it. Okay. I think you would like it. Okay. I'll watch the first 20 minutes of it.
是的。跟我说说咖啡机旁边的毛巾。你懂的。在前20分钟里，有没有什么迷人的随机细节我可以关注的？我相信你会发现的。太损了。好吧，继续。你对它还是没有释怀，这挺好的。我们有一个关于“第二人生”的粉丝提问，来自温斯顿·F、奥利维拉·洛韦尔、吉安娜·威廉姆斯
Yeah. Tell me about the towel next to the coffee pot. You got it. Is there a charming random detail I can hone in on in the first 20 minutes of the film? I'm sure you'll find it. So much shade. Okay, go on. It's good you're still not bitter about it though. We had a fan question about Second Life from Winston F., Olivia Lovell, Gianna Williams
和约翰·莱斯库姆。他们只是说，能请您告诉我们关于在《办公室》中使用《第二人生》的一切吗？为单集节目编程一个庞大的大型多人在线游戏似乎是一项巨大的工程。是谁想出来的？你们是怎么做到的？好吧，你知道我不得不联系谁。肯塔-肯塔-肯塔百科全书。肯塔百科全书。肯蒂联系了《第二人生》的开发者Clear Ink和Linden Labs，我们与他们签订了许可协议。他们最终为我们创建了所有的化身
and John Lescombe. They just said, can you please tell us everything about using Second and Second Life on the Office? It seems like such a big undertaking to program a whole massive multiplayer online game for a single episode. Who came up with it? How did you do it? Well, you know who I had to reach out to. Kent-a-kenta-kantapedia. Kentapedia. Kent reached out to the developers of Second Life, Clear Ink and Linden Labs and we entered into a license agreement with them. They ended up creating all of the avatars
和动画。肯蒂不得不把约翰和雷恩的照片发给那些家伙，他们根据杰森和格雷格的指导画出了他们的小化身，这就是他们制作它的过程。太酷了。而且肯蒂太棒了。我们每周都去找肯蒂。我知道。谢谢肯蒂。安吉拉，我们收到了一封来自辛·斯凯伯格的信，听听这个。当这一集播出时我在《第二人生》工作，我们太激动了。我当时是客户服务主管，我把我们整个团队虚拟地聚在一起观看这一集。过去和
and animation for us. Kent had to send pictures of John and Rain over to those guys and they drew out little avatars of them based on Jason and Greg's direction and that's how they made it. It's so cool. And Kent is so awesome. We go to Kent every week. I know. Thanks Kent. We got a letter, Angela, from SynSkyberg and listen to this. I worked at Second Life when this episode came out and we were so excited. I was the head of customer service at the time and I got all our team together virtually to watch the episode. Second Life was and
现在都是一个疯狂的地方，里面发生了太多真正疯狂的事情。这对我们所有人来说都是一个巨大的亮点。我敢打赌辛有一些好故事。没有。我不想打开那个潘多拉的盒子，因为我想，哦不，我不想给任何人惹麻烦。但多酷啊。我现在很好奇。太酷了。你准备好听快讯三了吗？
is a crazy place and so much really nuts stuff happened in there. This was a big highlight for all of us. I bet Syn has some good stories. No. I didn't want to open up that Pandora's box because I thought, oh no, I don't want to get anyone in trouble. But how cool. I am now curious. That is so cool. Are you ready for Fast Facts number three?
好的。我把这个叫做“奇巧巧克力趣味事实”。哦，你对奇巧巧克力进行了深度剖析吗？亲爱的，我当然做了。如你所知，在本集中，安迪这个角色记不起著名的广告歌的结尾了，给我一块休息，给我一块休息，掰一块我的奇巧巧克力棒。是的。所以我认为你们大家可能会想知道奇巧巧克力棒是在1930年
Yeah. I'm calling this one Kit Kat Fun Facts. Oh, did you do a deep dive on Kit Kats? Lady, of course I did. As you know, in this episode, the character of Andy cannot remember the end of the famous jingle, give me a break, give me a break, break me off a piece of that Kit Kat Bar. Yeah. So I thought you all might like to know that the Kit Kat Bar was brought to market in 1930
由英国约克的朗特里公司推出市场的。它的广告宣传语是“一杯茶的最佳伴侣”。约克的朗特里，巧克力制造商，其名下第七位，最佳伴侣，一杯茶。我不知道。对不起。我只是把所有东西都变成《权力的游戏》的头衔。尽管我从来没有像约翰·威克那样看完《权力的游戏》，安吉拉，我喜欢你编造的《权力的游戏》名字。
by Round Tree of York in the United Kingdom. It was advertised as the best companion to a cup of tea. Round Tree of York, maker of chocolate, seventh of its name, best companion, cup of tea. I don't know. I'm sorry. I just make everything a Game of Thrones title. Even though I never finished Game of Thrones like John Wick, I love your Game of Thrones names that you make, Angela.
谢谢。我觉得自己多少被注意到了。安迪记不住的那首歌谣于1986在美国首次亮相，它至今仍然是那首歌谣。词作者是肯·肖德曼，曲作者是迈克尔·A·莱文。原创的版本被凯莉·安德伍德、肖恩·科尔芬以及无数在广告中出现过的演员翻唱过。但有趣的地方来了。
Thank you. I feel seen somewhat. The jingle that Andy can't remember debuted in the United States in 1986, and it is still the jingle today. The words are by Ken Shouldman, and the music was written by Michael A. Levine. Versions of the original have been covered by Carrie Underwood, Sean Colvin, and countless actors who have been seen in the commercials. But here's where it gets interesting.
好吧。这首歌，奇巧巧克力广告歌，被辛辛那提大学的一位研究员在一项研究中提及，他宣称它是十大洗脑神曲之一。洗脑神曲是一段旋律或一段卡在你脑海里的歌曲。哦，是的。研究人员的名字叫詹姆斯·卡拉里斯，他研究了这种现象。为什么歌曲的片段会卡在我们的脑海里？他说这在他们生命中的某个时刻几乎发生在每个人身上，但他发现
Okay. This song, the Kit Kat jingle, was cited in a study by a researcher at the University of Cincinnati who declared it one of the top 10 earworms. An earworm is a bit of a melody or bit of a song that becomes stuck in your head. Oh, yes. The researcher's name is James Calaris, and he studied this phenomenon. Why do bits of songs get stuck in our heads? He said that it happens to almost everyone at some point in their life, but he found
这确实更多地发生在女性和音乐家身上。嗯。哈。我的脑海里一直回响着曼农的歌，好几年了。哦，好吧。那不在他的名单上，但你知道他的洗脑歌曲名单上有什么吗？让我们听听。智利餐厅的广告歌“Baby Back Ribs”。
that it did happen more to women and musicians. Hmm. Huh. I have had, by Mennon, stuck in my head for years. Oh, okay. That was not on his list, but do you know what was on his list of warmest songs? Let's hear it. The Chili's Jingle Baby Back Ribs.
哦，是的。它也曾在《办公室》中出现过。进入前十名的其他歌曲是：《We Will Rock You》、《Who Let the Dogs Out》、《碟中谍主题曲》、《Woop There It Is》、《狮子今晚睡着了》、《小小世界》和《YMCA》。这些都是洗脑歌曲。洗脑歌曲。好吧，我想曼农其实不是一首歌。
Oh, yes. Which has also been featured on The Office. The other songs that made the top 10 were, We Will Rock You. Do Let the Dogs Out, The Mission Impossible Theme Song, Woop There It Is, The Lion Sleeps Tonight, It's a Small World After All, and YMCA. Those are the warmest songs. The warmest songs. Well, I guess by Mennon isn't really a song.
不，但它是一段旋律。是的。所以你不会把整首歌困在脑子里。你只是把旋律的一小部分卡在脑子里。好了。好吧，我觉得每个人，你可能走上街头，把麦克风塞进某人的脸说，“给我一块休息”，他们就会立刻接下去。
No, but it's a bit of melody. Yes. So you don't get the whole song trapped in your head. You just get some little bit of the melody stuck in your head. Yeah. There you go. Well, I feel like everybody, you could probably walk down the street and stick a microphone in someone's face and say, give me a break, and they'd immediately go into it.
是的。每个人都知道。这就是我所有的了，亲爱的。我认为这些都是精彩的快讯。我很兴奋能进入这一集，而且我还有一些内容要讲。好吧，我希望这是一堆隐藏宝珠和交叉连结。我只是想提醒你，那是这一集的 主题。谢谢你的提醒。
Yeah. Everyone knows that. That's all I got, lady. I thought those were wonderful, fast facts. I'm excited to get into this episode, and I've got some stuff coming up. Well, I hope it's a ton of hidden gems and crossover connections. I just want to remind you that's the theme of this episode. Thank you for the reminder.
让我们休息一下，回来时带来更多的隐藏宝珠和《地方广告》。好的。所以这一集从一个会议室场景开始。迈克尔正让大家为即将到来的广告头脑风暴。他超级兴奋。一开场。菲利斯大喊，跳舞的婴儿。珍娜，你知道她在说什么，对吧？
Let's take a break and come back with some more hidden gems and local ad. All right. So this episode starts with a conference room scene. Michael is getting the gang to brainstorm ideas for their upcoming commercial. He's super excited. Right at the top. Phyllis shouts out, dancing baby. Jenna, you know what she's talking about, right?
有那些带有跳舞婴儿的广告，对吧？这是一个现象。好吧，这是我的小型深度剖析，伙计们。它被称为乌卡查卡婴儿。这是一个跳舞婴儿的3D渲染动画。它成了一个媒体现象。它是90年代最早的病毒视频之一。
There were those commercials with dancing babies in them, right? It was this phenomenon. Okay. Here's my little mini deep dive, guys. It's referred to as the Uka Chaka Baby. It was a 3D rendered animation of a baby dancing. It became a media phenomenon. It was one of the very first viral videos in the 90s.
这是这个跳舞婴儿动画。它传遍了所有这些流行的网络论坛、网站。它被发邮件给人们、演示视频、广告。最终，它进入了主流电视。它在CBS、CNN上播出。然后我记住它是从它最终成为艾莉·麦克比尔在她的节目中会有的那些幻想类事情的一部分开始的。哦，是的。
It was this dancing baby animation. It went all over these popular web forums, websites. It got emailed to people, demo videos, commercials. Eventually, it ended up in mainstream television. It was featured on CBS CNN. And then what I remember it from is it ended up being part of these fantasy kind of things that Allie McBeal would have on her show. Oh, yes.
对吧？是的，艾莉·麦克比尔里跳舞的婴儿。我记得那个。所以这是最早的病毒视频之一。我回去看了一下。太诡异了。太诡异了。我得把它发到我们的快拍里。
Right? Yes, the dancing baby on Allie McBeal. I remember that. So this was one of the very first viral videos. And I went back and watched it. It's so creepy. It's so creepy. I have to put it in our stories.
这简直是最诡异的事情了。美国，我们为什么会喜欢它？有时候你回过头来看，你会想，我们为什么对那个东西那么疯狂？我想因为我们从未见过类似的东西。这有点像是模因和动态图（gif或jif，你们怎么叫它们？）的开始。这是那的开始。这是一个3D动画婴儿伴随着这首歌尴尬地跳舞。人们当时想，哦天哪。
It is just the creepiest thing. America, what did we love about it? Sometimes you look back and you're like, why did we go so crazy over that thing? I think because we'd never seen anything like it. This was like sort of the beginning of what memes and gifs or gifs, what do you call those? This was the beginning of that. This was this 3D animated baby dancing awkwardly to this song. And people were like, oh my God.
亲爱的，同样在本集的最开始，我们在迈克尔的访谈特写背景中看到了来自琳达·凯、萨迪·凯和杰基·休伊特的粉丝抓包。安吉拉，你太不在状态了。那里发生了什么？大家注意，在16秒处，16秒。我知道。我有。我截了一张图。
Lady, also at the very beginning of this episode, we had a fan catch from Linda Kay, Sadie Kay, and Jackie Hewitt in the background of Michael's talking head. Angela, you are way out of character. What is going on there? It's at 16 seconds, everybody, 16 seconds. I know. I have it. I took a screen grab of it.
我 literalmente 笑得不行，然后我就开始聊起来了。你看到我的嘴在动吗？我太不在状态了。我显然没有意识到我在镜头里。因为他们会让史蒂夫在会议室外做访谈特写。我们在背景里，但有点模糊，你知道的？是的。而我没有意识到。
I am literally laughing and then I just start chatting away. You see my mouth going? I am so out of character. I clearly didn't realize I was in the shot. Because they would have Steve do talking heads right outside the conference room. And we were in the background, but it was like a little blurry, you know? Yeah. And I didn't realize.
但我看了看，那是雷恩、布莱恩、我、你和爱德。我想我在讲一个故事。你在全场全神贯注。你盘腿坐着，我们都围在你周围。你显然在讲一个非常有趣的故事。我知道。我也捕捉到了。太棒了。
But I looked and it's Rain, Brian, me, you, and Ed. And I guess I'm telling a story. You are holding court. You are seated with your legs crossed and we're all kind of standing around you. And you are clearly telling a very fun story. I know. I caught it too. It was amazing.
而且，这一集里还设定了一个出色的桥段，就是安迪记不住奇巧巧克力广告歌的结尾，而吉姆马上说，不要帮他，所以没人帮他。我知道。这太糟了。我知道。这也设定了帕姆自愿为迈克尔的广告制作一个标志。她要设计一个标志。她非常兴奋。
And also, it sets up in this scene, the great runner of Andy not being able to remember the end of the Kit Kat jingle, and Jim immediately says, don't help him, so no one helps him. I know. That is the worst. I know. It also sets up that Pam has volunteered to make a logo for Michael's commercial. She's going to design a logo. She's very excited.
好吧，她说她在上动画课。我喜欢这个。我知道。我当时想，加油，帕姆。广告小哥们到了，迈克尔跑出会议室，他马上要开始向他们推销他的创意了。他说他希望这个广告就像“吸毒过量的MTV”一样。他四处走动。
Well, she says she's taking an animation class. I love that. I know. I was like, go Pam. The ad guys arrive, Michael runs out of the conference room and he is immediately going to start pitching them his ideas. He says he wants this commercial to be like MTV on crack. He goes around.
他把他们介绍给办公室里的每个人。删除片段里还有更多。他简直走到每一个人面前，对他们所有人进行了糟糕的介绍。只有迈克尔能做到这一点。如果你想看更多尴尬、让人脚趾抠地的迈克尔式介绍，去看看删除片段吧。这两个广告小哥由凯尔·伯恩海默和金康饰演。你可能认得这些家伙。
He introduces them to everyone in the office. There's even more in the deleted scenes. He literally goes up to like every single person and does like a horrible introduction of all of them. The way only Michael can. If you want to see some more awkward, cringy Michael introductions, go to the deleted scenes. These two ad guys were played by Kyle Bornheimer and Tim Kang. You probably recognize these guys.
凯尔演过一大堆东西。他演过《神烦警探》。他拍过一堆广告。金也是一样。他后来成了《超感神探》和《夏威夷神探》重启版的常驻演员。是的。准备好迎接交叉连结了吗？放给我听。
Kyle has been on a ton of stuff. He was on Brooklyn Nine-Nine. He's done a bunch of commercials. Tim is the same way. He went on to be a regular on the mentalist and the reboot of Magnum PI. Yes. Are you ready for some crossover connection? Play them on me.
扮演蒂姆的金，准备好听这个了吗？他的女儿和我的女儿在2019年同一支足球队，猎鹰队。我是球队家长。我的前夫沃伦是教练。我们把事情办成了，各位。我们把事情办成了。猎鹰队打进了我们AYSO赛区的决赛。我们继续去踢地区季后赛，伙计们。
Tim, who plays Tim, ready for this? His daughter and my daughter were on the same soccer team in 2019, the Falcons. I was the team parent. My ex-husband Warren was the coach. We make it work, y'all. We make it work. And the Falcons made it to the finals in our AYSO division. We went on to play in the regional playoffs, you guys.
然后我们晋级到大区季后赛。女孩们获得第三名，她们是去州赛的亚军球队。亲爱的，我永远不会忘记在伊莎贝尔的足球队走得这么远的时候你给我发的信息。那是没完没了的足球年。确实是。我会给你发短信，然后我说，你在干嘛？而你说，亲爱的，我们还在踢这个足球锦标赛。
And then we advanced to the area playoffs. The girls came in third and they were the runner-up team to go to state. Lady, I will never forget your messages to me during this time of Isabelle's soccer team going so far. It was the never-ending year of soccer. It was. I would text you and I would say, what are you up to? And you're like, lady, we are still in this soccer tournament.
是的。但太令人兴奋了。我记得那些女孩有多兴奋。而金是另一个女孩的另一个家长。我喜欢这个。是的。所以金和我一起坐在边线为我们的女孩们加油。好吧，我和凯尔有连结。
Yes. But it was so exciting. I remember how excited those girls were. And Tim is one of the other parents of another girl. I love that. Yes. So Tim and I have sat on the sidelines together and cheered our girls on. Well, I have a connection to Kyle.
没有那个那么令人兴奋。但我们俩都参演了电影《冰刀双人组》。他扮演冰场公共广播播音员。所以我想在某种程度上，我们也曾坐在看台上为一个体育赛事的溜冰加油，尽管是虚构的。是的。好吧，安吉拉，我还有另一个交叉连结给你。我想我知道这个。
It's not as exciting as that. But we were both in the movie Blades of Glory. He played the rink PA announcer. And so I guess in a way, we also both sat in stands and cheered on a sporting event of ice skating, though fictional. Yes. Well, I have another crossover connection for you, Angela. I think I know this one.
这个真的很奇怪，而且会贯穿整集。就像这一集的每个客串明星一样，《地方广告》也在《神探阿蒙》里客串过。太疯狂了，对吧？这到底是怎么回事？凯尔在《阿蒙先生与孩子》中扮演制服警察，金在《阿蒙先生彻夜未眠》中扮演布伦南先生。我知道。对我来说太疯狂了。
This one's really weird, and it's going to be a runner through this whole episode. Like every guest star in this episode, local ad has also had a guest appearance on Monk. It's so wild, isn't it? What is going on? Kyle played uniform cop in Mr. Monk and the Kid, and Tim played Mr. Breneman in Mr. Monk is up all night. I know. It's so wild to me.
我们还有更多交叉连结，但这是你的前两个。现在我们进入这一集，开场是德怀特在玩“第二人生”。珍娜，在3分39秒，是只有我觉得德怀特飞起来的样子像《异星灾变》里的母亲吗？我不知道《异星灾变》。我知道。我就知道你会知道。这听起来和《权力的游戏》很像。
We have more crossover connections coming up, but there's your first two. Now we get into this episode, and it opens with Dwight playing Second Life. And Jenna, at three minutes, 39 seconds, is it just me or does Dwight fly like mother in Raised by Wolves? I don't know Raised by Wolves. I know. I knew you would know it. This sounds very similar to Game of Thrones.
好吧，《异星灾变》一点也不像《权力的游戏》。它只是HBO Max上最诡异的节目。以下是《异星灾变》的概述。两个机器人被委任在一个神秘星球上抚养人类儿童，而人类殖民地因宗教分歧面临撕裂的威胁。机器人们了解到，控制人类的信仰是一项危险而艰巨的任务。此外机器人的母亲能够生孩子。这太离奇了，珍娜。
Okay, Raised by Wolves is nothing like Game of Thrones. It is just the weirdest show on HBO Max. Here's the overview of Raised by Wolves. Two androids are tasked with raising human children on a mysterious planet as the human colony threatens to be torn apart by religious differences. The androids learn that controlling the beliefs of humans is treacherous and a difficult task. Also the androids mother is able to have babies. It's very bizarre, Jenna.
太离奇了。我一点也不奇怪我宁愿看《最后 Tango 在哈利法克斯》也不看《异星灾变》。现在听着，《最后 Tango 在哈利法克斯》正合我意。你知道我喜欢任何BBC节目，但我同样喜欢一些诡异的科幻片。好的，我给你看。这就是德怀特在《简单生活》中飞行的方式，这就是母亲飞行的方式。我看到了。
It's so bizarre. It is not a surprise to me that I'm watching Last Tango and Halifax instead of Raised by Wolves. Now listen, Last Tango and Halifax is right up my alley. You know I love any kind of like BBC programming, but I also love me some weird sci-fi. Okay, I'm going to show you. This is how Dwight flies in Simple Life, and this is how mother flies. I see it.
他们都是直立的，手臂伸开。非常诡异。我知道。任何看过《异星灾变》的人，去3分39秒。看德怀特是如何起飞的，这会让你想起母亲。安吉拉也会把这个发到播客上。我要把它发到我们的故事里。我查了德怀特在“第二人生”上的个人资料。
They both go upright with their arms out. It's very creepy. I know. Anyone else that watched Raised by Wolves, go to 3 minutes 39 seconds. Watch how Dwight does his lift off, and it will remind you of mother. Angela will also put that on the pod. I'm going to put it in our stories. I looked up Dwight's profile on Second Life.
真的吗？真的。它还在那。以下是他在兴趣一栏填写的：学校汽车、流行文化和科幻迷，括号里写着《哈利波特》、《指环王》、《星球大战》、《24小时》、《超人前传》、《学徒》、《迷失》和《太空堡垒卡狄加》。他的才艺列为：玉米皮玩偶制作高手、节拍雕塑家和打结冠军。他必须为他的“第二人生”列出一个目标，他写道：计算
You did? I did. It's still there. Here's what he has down as his interests. School cars, pop culture, and sci-fi buff, in parentheses, Harry Potter, The Lord of the Rings, Star Wars, 24, Alias Smallville, The Apprentice, Lost and Battlestar Galactica. His talents are listed as Avid Cornhusk Dollmaker, Beat Sculptor, and Not Tying Champion. He had to list a goal for his Second Life, and he wrote, to calculate the exchange between
精明币和林登币之间的兑换。林登币是“第二人生”中的货币。好吧。就是这样。当他不像母亲那样飞翔时，他正试图计算精明币和林登币之间的汇率。我喜欢这个。接下来，迈克尔要向广告小哥们推销他的大创意。
Shrewt Bucks and Lyndon Dollars. Lyndon Dollars are the currency in Second Life. Okay. There you have it. When he's not flying like mother, he is trying to calculate the exchange between Shrewt Bucks and Lyndon Dollars. I love that. Up next, Michael is going to pitch his big idea to the ad guys.
我想让你们知道，在这之前本该有一个删除片段，在吉姆和迈克尔之间，非常美妙有趣。实际上迈克尔想对吉姆进行练习推销。他把吉姆带进办公室，对吧？他让吉姆坐在他的桌子后面，以便他可以练习推销，他说，这是他对吉姆的推销。我们从一张白纸开始。镜头拉远展现古罗马。吉姆说，不行。
I want you guys to know a deleted scene would have come before this between Jim and Michael that is so delicious and fun. Actually Michael wants to practice pitch to Jim. He brings Jim in the office, right? He has Jim sit behind his desk so he can practice pitch, and he says, this is his pitch to Jim. We start on a blank piece of paper. We widen to reveal ancient Rome. Jim's like, can't do that.
迈克尔说，好吧，我们拉远展现一艘飞船从一个女人的子宫里炸出来。什么？然后他们进行了一场非常有趣的即兴表演，吉姆说，滚出我的办公室。这变成了一整件事。但实际上，迈克尔最终确定的推销是这个，我觉得我们必须听听。萨姆，你能播放吗？田野里的小女孩，花朵里的洞。
Michael's like, okay, we widen to reveal a spaceship blasting out of a woman's womb. What? Then they do this very funny role play where Jim's like, get out of my office. His like becomes a whole thing. But for real, the pitch Michael settles on is this one, and I thought we had to hear it. Sam, can you play it? Little girl in a field, hole in a flower.
我们向后拉镜头发现她在沙漠里，而田野是一处绿洲。再往后拉。沙漠是世界最大度假村酒店里的一个沙坑。再往后拉，酒店实际上是世界最大监狱的游乐场。但我们再向后拉。好吧。我看得出来你的时间很宝贵。哦，好吧，我喜欢当那个人说，听着，我看得出来你的时间很宝贵时迈克尔说的话。
We zoom back to find that she's in the desert, and the field is an oasis. Zoom back further. The desert is a sandbox in the world's largest resort hotel. Zoom back further, the hotel is actually the playground of the world's largest prison. But we zoom back further. Okay. I can tell that your time is valuable. Oh, well, I love what he says when the guy is like, listen, I can tell your time is valuable.
迈克尔说，好吧，实际上，我不再按小时拿工资了。我按年拿工资。所以基本上，我想浪费多少时间就浪费多少时间。没问题。是的。我喜欢这是他开场的主打推销，而且知道他还有其他想法，但他选了这个。广告小哥们太棒了。
And Michael's like, well, actually, I don't get paid by the hour anymore. I get paid by the year. So basically, I can waste as much time as I want. Not a problem. Yes. I love that this is the pitch that he led with and knowing that he had other ideas, but this is what he went with. The ad guys are great.
他们在对迈克尔做出反应时非常真实。他们说，听着，我们为纳什维尔分公司制作了一个。为什么不给你们看看呢？这会让你们对我们能做什么有个概念。所以他播放了这个广告，然后他们解释说，他们唯一被允许修改的广告部分最后五秒钟。是的。迈克尔说，什么？
They're so real in how they react to Michael. They say, listen, we made something for the Nashville branch. Why don't we show that to you? And it'll give you an idea of what we can do. So he plays this commercial, and then they explain the only part of the commercial they're allowed to alter is the last five seconds. Yeah. And Michael's like, what?
最后他说，你不觉得你可以鼓掌，你知道的，把它变成你自己的。是的。这就是你可以真正发挥创意的地方。你可以在里面。你可以在外面。我们有一个粉丝提问，来自亚伦、贾萨、哈里·德里斯科尔、莫莉·科茨和许多其他人。他们想知道谁导演了这个在剧集中间播放的广告。是杰森·雷特曼吗？
And at the end, he goes, aren't you know, you could clap, you know, make it your own. Yeah. This is where you can really get creative. You can be inside. You can be outside. We had a fan question, Aaron, Jassa, Harry Driscoll, Molly Coats, and many others. They wanted to know who directed this commercial that plays in the middle of the episode. Was it Jason Reitman?
是的。是杰森·雷特曼。我给BJ发短信谈到这个广告，他告诉我杰森·雷特曼之前导演过真正的广告。在此之前，他记得这太酷了，因为杰森在地板上铺了一条巨大的圆形轨道，让摄像机绕着圈拍，BJ当时想，我从没见过这样的东西。太酷了。
Yes. It was Jason Reitman. I texted with BJ about this commercial, and he told me that Jason Reitman had directed real commercials. Before this, and he remembers that it was so cool because Jason laid out this big circular track on the floor and had the camera going around in circles, and BJ was like, I had never seen anything like that before. It was so cool.
好吧，我们问了杰森关于拍摄这个假广告的事，以下是他的言论。剧集《地方广告》里面包含两个广告，我曾是一名广告导演。我应该说，我是一个糟糕的广告导演。你知道，我导演的大多数广告，如果你看到了，你会吊销我的导演执照，你只会说你不被允许再次导演。我会说出客户的名字，但这会很不礼貌。但你知道的，典型的快餐和啤酒，作品并不算出色。
Well we asked Jason about filming this fake commercial, and here's what he had to say. The episode local ad contained two commercials inside it, and I had been a commercial director. I was a bad commercial director, I should say. You know, the majority of the commercials that I directed were ones that if you saw, you would revoke my director-skilled card, you would just say you're not allowed to direct again. I would name clients, but that would be rude. But you know, typical fast food and beer, and just not good work.
我不是斯派克·琼斯。但我学会了那种形式。有些事情你可能不知道如何真实地去做，但你知道如何讽刺。我知道我永远无法导演大卫·芬奇的电影，但我太崇拜他作为电影制作人了，以至于我可能能够导演对大卫·芬奇电影的讽刺。所以虽然我不知道如何导演一个伟大的广告，但我认为我知道如何导演一个好广告的讽刺。
I was not Spike Jonze. But I learned that format. There's certain things that you may not know how to do authentically, but you know how to satirize. I know that I could never direct a David Fincher film, but I love him so much as a filmmaker that I could probably direct a satire of a David Fincher film. And so I don't know how to direct a great commercial, but I think I know how to direct the satire of a good commercial.
而这正是制作邓德·米夫林广告的妙处所在，我觉得我的广告大脑在试图制作邓德·米夫林会交托给迈克尔·斯科特的最好的、最糟糕的版本，也就是这种有点老土的广告。它由杰夫·维茨基主演，他是我从小合作到大的演员。他literally演了我的第一部短片，从那以后我制作的所有东西他都演了。他是主演，这太棒了。我喜欢杰森在他的所有作品中都用他的朋友杰夫。我只是觉得这太棒了。
And that was the kind of, the great thing about doing the Dunder Mifflin ad was I felt my commercial brain trying to do the best, worst version of what Dunder Mifflin would hand Michael Scott, which was this kind of cutesy commercial. It starred Jeff Whitsky, who is an actor I've worked with since I was a kid. He literally was in my first short film and has been in everything I've ever made since. And he was the star of it and that was great. I love that Jason just uses his friend Jeff in everything. I just think that's wonderful.
珍娜，我希望你从今以后参与我做的所有事情。太好了。我喜欢。好的。好吧，我们和杰夫有一些交叉连结。准备好了吗？他还参演了由敏迪·卡灵和布兰达·威瑟斯编剧的电视短片《敏迪和布兰达》。哦。
Jenna, I want you to be in everything I do from here on out. Great. I love it. Okay. Well, we have some crossover connections with Jeff. Are you ready? He was also in Mindy and Brenda, the TV short written by Mindy Kaling and Brenda Whithers. Oh.
是的。他扮演售货员。你知道吗，亲爱的，你猜怎么着？他还在《神探阿蒙》里客串过。他在《阿蒙先生去马戏团》里扮演人体大炮。那个真的击中我了。我可能需要去查查那个。人体大炮。
Yeah. He played the sales clerk. You know, lady, guess what? He also did a guest spot on Monk. He played human cannonball and Mr. Monk goes to the circus. That one really got me. I might need to look that one up. Human cannonball.
非常好奇。你可能需要看看人体大炮长什么样。是的。杰森不仅再次雇用了杰夫，他还雇用了他以前合作过的一位朋友来谱曲。这有点像，我不知道，就像背景里播放的萨尔萨音乐。他是为《朱诺》创作所有音乐的同一个人作曲的，马特奥·梅西纳。我喜欢这个。
Very curious. You might need to see what the human cannonball looks like. Yes. So not only did Jason hire Jeff again, he also hired a friend that he had worked with before to compose that music. That's sort of like, I don't know, it's like salsa music that's playing in the background. He was composed by the same composer that did all the music for Juno, Matteo Messina. I love that.
现在事情要变得尴尬了。安迪把德怀特拉到一边，征求如何与安吉拉有进一步发展的建议。他说他们一直在疯狂贴面，但这字面意思就是他们的脖子互相摩擦。根本没有接吻。为什么我们没有那种素材？我不知道。我不知道。
Now things are going to get awkward. Andy pulls Dwight aside to get advice on how to get to first base with Angela. He says they've been necking a lot, but that means that they are literally rubbing their necks together. There's no kissing involved. Why don't we have any footage of that? I don't know. I don't know.
现在事情变得尴尬了。安迪把德怀特拉到一边，向他请教如何能和安吉拉有进一步的发展。他说他们一直在“贴脸”，但那字面意思真的是把脖子贴在一起，根本没有接吻。为什么我们没有拍到那个画面？我不知道。我不知道。
I don't know. Angela, we had a fan question from Amy Noki. She's dying to know what is your backstory for Angela and Andy and what is with the necking? Do you think this was standard for Angela or is it because she can't stomach Andy and she's just trying to get back at Dwight? I love this question. I thought that Angela went out with Andy as sort of a revenge date. She was very mad at Dwight.
我不知道。安吉拉，有个粉丝艾米·诺基（Amy Noki）提问。她非常想知道你对安吉拉和安迪的背景设定是什么？还有那些亲热是怎么回事？你觉得这符合安吉拉的一贯作风，还是因为她根本受不了安迪，只是想借此报复德怀特？我喜欢这个问题。我觉得安吉拉和安迪约会有点像报复性约会。她当时对德怀特非常生气。
She really thought she was done with Dwight. She was super, super angry with him. As she started dating Andy, I think it became very clear to her that really Dwight had her heart, but she was too prideful to admit that. She tried to date Andy, but it was a chore. I think the necking thing is just something she was doing to put him off. How can I let him touch me, but not really touch me? I think her heart wasn't in it from the beginning.
她真的以为自己和德怀特彻底完了。她对德怀特超级超级生气。随着她开始和安迪约会，我想她渐渐发现，其实德怀特才拥有她的真心，但她太骄傲了，不肯承认。她试着和安迪约会，但这成了一种苦差事。我觉得那种亲热只是她用来敷衍他的手段。我怎么能让他碰我，但又不是真的碰我呢？我觉得她从一开始就没把心思放在他身上。
Yeah. I was thinking about it. You know, Angela can be very fussy and very structured, but we saw her going at it in Jim's little toy playhouse thing, an email surveillance, so when she's into someone, it's not like she puts people through these weird paces of like, okay, first we just rub our necks together. I think this was exclusive to Andy. Oh yeah.
是啊。我之前也在想。你知道的，安吉拉可能很挑剔、很有条理，但在“电子邮件监视”那一集里，我们看到她在吉姆的小玩具游戏屋里玩得很嗨。所以当她对某人来电时，她才不会把对方折磨得这么古怪，比如“好吧，首先我们先蹭蹭脖子”。我觉得这只是对安迪特有的。哦，是的。
Yeah. And maybe the senator too. Perhaps. I really think Dwight was the love of her life. It just took them a while to get there. Poor Dwight. He's having to listen to all this and he tries to put Andy off. He says, I don't think we should talk about this.
对，也许对参议员也是这样。可能吧。我真心觉得德怀特才是她此生挚爱。他们只是花了点时间才走到这一步。可怜的德怀特。他得听着这一切，还试图阻止安迪。他说，我觉得我们不该聊这个。
People might overhear us, but then Andy just takes that to mean that they should come up with code names. Yeah. Dwight's like, okay, well, Angela can stay the same, but let's change Andy to Dwight. Hmm. Okay. Yeah. And Andy's like, that's not really, that's not how this works.
大家可能会偷听到，但安迪却觉得意思是他们应该用代号。没错。德怀特说，好吧，安吉拉还是叫安吉拉，但我们把安迪改成德怀特。嗯。好吧。对。然后安迪说，这其实不对，事情不是这样的。
Lady, this really reminded me of how you and I tried to come up with code names when we would have conversations and we were afraid other people could overhear us. Yeah. And our code names were about this good. They were so obvious. It would be like a person's initials. So obvious. I know.
姑娘，这真让我想起以前咱俩聊天时，担心被别人偷听，于是也试图想出一些代号。对。而且我们的代号就是这么烂。太明显了。差不多就是用人的首字母缩写。太明显了。就是说。
We're not going to be spies, Jenna. We're not going to be spies, but we're going to be mom detectives solving small crimes. I would love to be a mom detective with you when the pandemic is over. Mom detectives solving the small crimes no one cares about in your neighborhood. It's a hit. Who graffitied the construction cone at the intersection? Exactly. We'll find out.
珍娜，我们成不了间谍的。我们成不了间谍，但我们要当解决小案子的妈妈侦探。疫情结束之后，我好想和你一起当妈妈侦探。妈妈侦探专门侦破你社区里根本没人关心的那些小案子。这绝对是个爆款。谁在十字路口给交通锥喷了涂鸦？没错。我们会查出来的。
We'll tell you, we're on it. So coming up, we have a scene between Ryan and Michael that is so funny to me. And Michael calls him, you know, to gripe, first of all, he calls him Rye. And then Ryan is like, don't call me about small problems. What have I told you about that? Yeah. And he says, well, you don't like it when I call you about big problems either. So what do you want from me?
我们会告诉你，包在我们身上。接下来，瑞恩和迈克尔之间有一场戏，我觉得太搞笑惹。迈克尔打电话给他，你知道的，主要是为了抱怨，首先他叫他“莱”（Rye）。然后瑞恩就说，别为小问题烦我。我跟你说过多少次了？对。然后迈克尔说，好吧，我为大问题打电话给你，你也不高兴。那你到底想让我怎么样？
What do you want? So Jason said on the DVD commentary that they shot this in real time. Now, Jenna, do you remember they had built a little office that was Ryan's office at corporate, right? Yeah. And they had BJ, you know, on the other side of the soundstage in this little room with a camera with him. And then they had a camera with Steve in his office as Michael.
你到底想怎样？所以杰森在DVD评论里说，这部分他们是实时拍摄的。现在，珍娜，你还记得吗，他们在总公司搭了一个小办公室，就是瑞恩的办公室，对吧？对。他们让BJ在声场的另一头，在那个小房间里放着一个摄像机陪着他。然后迈克尔的办公室里也有一个摄像机对着史蒂夫。
And that's the room Jason sat in. And they shot it simultaneously. And I think it really works because the chemistry is happening in real time. I always loved when we did that because it meant that you could improvise a little and the other person could react to you and you would get it on both cameras. Yes. And BJ said something I thought was so delightful because it's one of my favorite lines in this whole episode.
那正是杰森坐的房间。他们是同时拍摄的。我觉得效果真的很棒，因为化学反应是实时发生的。我一直很喜欢我们那样做，因为这意味着你可以稍微即兴发挥一下，对方也能对你做出反应，而且两个摄像机都能捕捉到。没错。而且BJ说了一句我觉得特别有意思的话，因为这是整集里我最喜欢的台词之一。
BJ said he wrote the line, I can't cook and I'm starting a restaurant. And the restaurant he says he's going to start is Mike's Cereal Shack. It's going to have every cereal you can get in the store. Yeah. I want you to know I did a little bit of a deep dive on Mike's Cereal Shack. I had to know. Has anyone opened a cereal shack? The answer is no, but a woman named Catherine has designed the most adorable vintage poster
BJ说他写了这样一句台词：“我不会做饭，但我正打算开一家餐馆。”而他说要开的那家餐馆叫“麦克的麦片小屋”（Mike's Cereal Shack）。里面会有你在店里能买到的所有麦片。对。我想让你们知道，我稍微深入了解了一下“麦克的麦片小屋”。我非得搞清楚不可。有人开过麦片小屋吗？答案是没有，但有个叫凯瑟琳的女人设计了最可爱的复古海报，
for Mike's Cereal Shack. She has a company on Etsy called Cat Bone Design. It's so, so cute. I'm going to put a picture of it in the pod. And then her profile really got me, Ange. Her profile says I'm a stay at home mom with a passion for creating colorful and happy homes. The design keeps me balanced and brings me joy. And being a designer means I can share that joy with others.
就是为“麦克的麦片小屋”设计的。她在Etsy上开了一家叫“猫骨头设计”（Cat Bone Design）的公司。超级超级可爱。我会在播客里放一张它的照片。然后她的个人简介真的吸引了我，安吉。她的简介上写着：我是一名全职妈妈，热衷于创造色彩斑斓、充满欢乐的家。设计让我保持平衡并带给我快乐，而身为设计师意味着我可以把这份快乐分享给他人。
Jenna shared it with me. It is adorable. We're going to put it in our stories, you guys, so you can look at the rest of her art. There's one more thing I want to say about this scene before we move on. Ryan's assistant. Yes. She pokes her head in the door at the beginning and she says, Eddie Murphy is on the line for you.
珍娜把它分享给我了。太可爱了。大家，我们会把它发到动态里，这样你们就可以欣赏她其他的艺术作品了。在我们继续往下聊之前，关于这场戏我还有一件事想说。瑞恩的助理。对。她在开头探进头来说：“埃迪·墨菲（Eddie Murphy）有您的电话。”
Yes. Well, Ryan's assistant was played by Virginia Newcombe. And I'll have you know she has not been on an episode of Monk. I know. I looked to see if she was on Monk too. But she has been on The Walking Dead. Oh, so no crossover connection, but perhaps you recognize her from The Walking Dead. So Michael says, you know what?
对的。好吧，瑞恩的助理是由弗吉尼亚·纽康（Virginia Newcombe）饰演的。我得告诉你们，她可没演过《神探阿蒙》（Monk）。我知道。我查过她有没有演过《神探阿蒙》。但她演过《行尸走肉》（The Walking Dead）。哦，所以没有交叉客串的联系，不过你可能在《行尸走肉》里认出过她。所以迈克尔就说，你知道吗？
Ad guys go away. I'm going to do this on my own. He's going to stake his whole reputation on it. Oh yeah. Yeah. He calls David Wallace. Yeah. And he says, listen, I'm going to make it.
广告狂人们都走开。我自己来搞定。他打算把自己的全部名誉都押在这上面。哦，是的。没错。他给大卫·华莱士打电话。对。然后他说，听着，我能把它做好。
If you don't like it, fine. I'll bring those guys back and I'll pay for it on my own dime. I need to do this. Well, he leads off the whole call with, I don't know who talks to their boss like this. I would never talk to a boss like this. He's like, hey, yeah, Ryan's being a little bitch again. And Ryan goes, I'm on the call, Michael. And he's like, hey, bro.
如果你不喜欢，没关系。我把那些家伙叫回来，我自己掏腰包付钱。我必须得这么做。好吧，他一开场就说——我都不知道有谁会这样跟老板说话。我绝不会这样跟老板说话。他就说：“嘿，对，瑞恩又在当个小碧池了。”然后瑞恩说：“我在通话呢，迈克尔。”接着他说：“嘿，兄弟。”
Like so awkward. I just love Ryan's matter of factness. He is never rattled by Michael being Michael and he's so direct and honest with Michael. He is to Michael what Daryl is to Kelly. Yes. Just the straight truth. And I feel like neither one of them knows how to handle that. Not at all.
简直太尴尬了。我就是喜欢瑞恩那种对事不对人的态度。迈克尔还是那个迈克尔，但他从来不会被吓到，而且他对迈克尔总是那么直接和诚实。他对迈克尔，就像达里尔对凯利一样。没错。就是说实话。而且我觉得他俩谁都不知道该怎么应付这种性格。完全不会。
This scene with BJ as Ryan just being very direct reminded me the most of who BJ is in real life. It's true. And he's very fair, but he'll break it down for you. He'll be like, I don't think you should do that. And here's why. You know? And it's what I love about him.
这场由BJ饰演的瑞恩表现得非常直接的戏，最让我想起现实生活中的BJ是个什么样的人。确实如此。他非常公正，但他会把事情给你剖析清楚。他会说：“我觉得你不应该那样做，原因如下。”你知道吗？这也是我喜欢他的地方。
Me too. Everybody needs that friend who doesn't blow smoke up your ass, frankly. You need that person that you can call and you know which friends are which friends. You know the friends you call when you want them to agree with you. And then you need that friend that you can call to get the straight truth. Right. And BJ is that friend. You can call him, but you have to be prepared to hear the real answer.
我也是。说实话，每个人都需要那种不会拍你马屁的朋友。你需要那种你可以打电话给对方的朋友，而且你知道哪些朋友是哪类朋友。你知道当你希望别人赞同你时该给哪个朋友打电话。然后你需要那种能打电话去听实话的朋友。没错。BJ就是那种朋友。你可以打电话给他，但你必须做好听到真实答案的准备。
Not what you want to hear, but what you need to hear. Yes. It's like having the friend that tells you the piece of broccoli is in your teeth. Yes. You need that friend. Yes. I have a little bit of a fan catch from this phone call scene coming in from Ohm Patel and Mina Hoyt.
不是你想听的，而是你需要听的。没错。这就好比有个朋友会提醒你牙缝里沾了菜叶一样。没错。你需要这样的朋友。没错。从这个电话场景里，我收集到了来自奥姆·帕特尔（Ohm Patel）和米娜·霍伊特（Mina Hoyt）的一些粉丝彩蛋。
When David Wallace and Michael are on the call, the camera keeps swishing down to the phone. At first, the time on the phone shows that it is 9.38. But at the end of the call, the clock shows 9.22. That's a good catch. I want you to know that the date on the clock says October 3rd, 2007. That is when we shot this episode. I think that clock is the real time they were shooting this episode.
当大卫·华莱士和迈克尔在通话时，镜头不断扫向电话。起初，电话上的时间显示是9点38分。但到了通话结束时，时钟显示是9点22分。这是一个很好的细节抓取。我想让你们知道，时钟上的日期显示是2007年10月3日。那是我们拍摄这一集的时候。我觉得那个时钟就是他们拍摄这一集的实时时间。
They shot it in the morning around 9 a.m. on October 3rd, 2007. I'm positive of that. So Michael's about to gather everyone in the conference room, but maybe we should take a break and then we'll come back and get into his big ideas for his big commercial. They have a huge shoot ahead of them, all hands on deck. I know. Sue Grafton. Sue Grafton.
他们在2007年10月3日上午9点左右拍的。我对此百分之百确定。所以迈克尔马上要把大家召集到会议室里了，不过也许我们应该休息一下，然后再回来聊聊他为自己的超级广告制定的那些宏伟构想。他们接下来有一场重头戏要拍，全员出动。我懂。苏·格拉夫顿（Sue Grafton）。苏·格拉夫顿。
We'll be back. Okay. Okay, we are back and everyone is in the conference room. Michael is giving a big pep talk about how everyone is creative. Don't let anyone tell you that you're not creative. And this leads into a series of talking heads. And I want you guys to know there are even more in the deleted scenes. Pretty much every single person had a talking head in this episode, but not all of them
我们一会儿回来。好的。好了，我们回来了，大家都在会议室里。迈克尔正在发表鼓舞士气的慷慨陈词，讲每个人都很有创造力。不要让任何人对你说你没有创造力。这随后引发了一系列的访谈镜头。我想让你们知道，被删减的片段里甚至还有更多。几乎每个人在这集里都有访谈镜头，但并不是所有镜头都
made it in. So now Michael starts delegating jobs to people in preparation for this big commercial shoot. Yes. He says, Kelly, makeup, Oscar, costume design, guys, go to 10 minutes, four seconds. Oscar shoots a look directly to camera, right down the barrel. That is so great. When Michael says costume design, look at that moment. And then he says, Phyllis, get a celebrity.
保留了下来。现在迈克尔开始把工作分配给大伙儿，为这个大型广告拍摄做准备。是的。他说，凯利负责化妆，奥斯卡负责服装设计，大家，看到10分04秒。奥斯卡直接对着镜头看了一眼，直视镜头。太棒了。当迈克尔说“服装设计”时，看那个眼神。然后他说，菲利斯，去请个名人来。
Yes. When we move out into the bullpen, this is when Phyllis learns that Sue Grafton, the mystery novelist, is at the Steamtown Mall doing a book signing. And Michael says, go, Phyllis, go. You go get her. You convince her to be in our commercial and don't take no for an answer. He says, yeah, this will be a big coop. Big coop.
对。当我们走到开放式办公区时，菲利斯得知推理小说家苏·格拉夫顿正在蒸汽镇购物中心（Steamtown Mall）举办新书签售会。迈克尔说：“去吧，菲利斯，去吧。你去把她找来。你得说服她来拍我们的广告，别接受‘不’这个答案。”他说，这会是一次重大的政变。不对，是重大斩获（Coop）。
This is when Andy is going to try to butter up Angel a little bit by asking if Sue Grafton is attractive. To which Creed says, oh, yeah, she's super hot. And Andy says, maybe Angela should just pretend to be Sue Grafton in the commercial since Angela is also super hot. Yeah. Angela's like, that's not going to happen. It's not going to happen because as you reveal in your talking head, you find the mystery
这时安迪试图通过询问苏·格拉夫顿是否有吸引力来拍安吉拉的马屁。对此克里德说：“哦，对，她超级辣。”安迪便说：“也许安吉拉可以在广告里假扮苏·格拉夫顿，因为安吉拉也超级辣。”对。安吉拉说：“这是不可能发生的。”绝对不会发生，因为正如你在访谈中透露的那样，你觉得推理
genre disgusting and you hate being titillated. Angela, we had a fan question from Chloe M. She would like to know how many takes did it take for you to get out the line? I hate being titillated without laughing. Chloe, I think they used the only one. I think I only did one where I didn't laugh. We were cracking up. Angela Martin is just wired so tight.
小说这种类型太令人作呕了，而且你讨厌被挑逗。安吉拉，我们有一个来自克洛伊·M（Chloe M）的粉丝提问。她想知道，为了说出“我讨厌被挑逗却又忍不住发笑”这句台词，你拍了多少条？克洛伊，我觉得他们只用了唯一的那一条。我想我只拍了一条没笑的。我们当时都笑疯了。安吉拉·马丁的神经就是绷得这么紧。
I laughed at just saying the mystery genre was disgusting. Disgusting. Disgusting. I love every time Angela has very, very strong feelings on random subjects such as this. I do too. Well, you know, I had an alternate talking head that didn't make it in. I guess they were deciding between which one. I definitely think they picked the best one, but I want to share with you what the alternate
我光是说“推理小说这种类型令人作呕”这句话就笑场了。令人作呕。令人作呕。我每次看到安吉拉对诸如此类的随机话题有着极其强烈的情感时，我都觉得很棒。我也是。好吧，你知道的，我有一个没被采用的备选访谈镜头。我猜他们当时在纠结该选哪一个。我绝对觉得他们选了最好的一版，但我还是想跟你们分享一下备选的
talking head is. It's in the deleted scenes. In this deleted talking head, Angela Martin says, this is not my first commercial. When I was in high school, I played a six-year-old in an electronic store ad and it was humiliating. I mean, how small was I in high school that I could be passed for a six-year-old? I love it. And who made her do this? Did she have a stage mom?
访谈镜头是什么样的。它在删减片段里。在这个被删掉的访谈镜头里，安吉拉·马丁说：“这可不是我拍的第一支广告。我上高中时，曾在一个电子产品店的广告里演过一个六岁小孩，那简直太屈辱了。我是说，我上高中时到底长得多小，才能被误认为是个六岁小孩啊？”我太喜欢了。是谁让她这么干的？她有个星妈吗？
Did Angela Martin have a stage mom? I don't know. You did the pageant. Right. I did pageants. And now I did commercials. What was her childhood? We had a fan question from Jay Tickle.
安吉拉·马丁有个星妈吗？我不知道。你参加过选美比赛。对啊。我参加过选美。然后后来我拍了广告。她的童年到底是怎么样的？我们收到了来自杰伊·蒂克尔（Jay Tickle）的粉丝提问。
Can y'all talk about any commercials you've been in? Oh, Jay. I was in so many. That's how I like supported myself. I was an operator at 1-800-Dennis and I did commercials. When I moved to Los Angeles, my one connection that I had was that my roommate had a commercial agent. And I was convinced that all I had to do was give this commercial agent my headshot and
你们能聊聊你们拍过的广告吗？哦，杰伊。我拍过好多呢。我就是靠那个养活自己的。我曾是1-800-丹尼斯（1-800-Dennis）的接线员，我还拍过广告。我搬到洛杉矶时，手里仅有的人脉就是我室友有个广告经纪人。我当时确信，我只要把自己的头像照交给这个广告经纪人，
this person would also become my commercial agent. That did not happen. It took me about two years to find a commercial agent and then I never booked a single commercial in a speaking role. Ever in my whole career as an actress, I have never been in a commercial. I've been in the background of many commercials. I did a lot of background work and then finally, about a year ago, I was approached by Smirnoff Vodka to be in a commercial with Ted Danson.
这个人也会成为我的广告经纪人。结果并没有发生。我花了大约两年时间才找到一个广告经纪人，然后我再也没有接到过一句有台词的角色。在我的整个演员生涯中，我从来没有演过有台词的广告。我演过很多广告的背景路人。我做了很多背景板工作，然后终于在大约一年前，我被诗珞露伏特加（Smirnoff Vodka）邀请去和泰德·丹森（Ted Danson）一起拍广告。
I flipped out. My mom was so excited. She said, Jenna, you're finally going to be in a commercial 20 years later. Finally booked a commercial. Jenna, I loved that commercial you did with Ted Danson. I thought it was so stinking cute. I did a ton of commercials. I did a Buick spot.
我简直高兴疯了。我妈妈超级兴奋。她说：“珍娜，20年过去了，你终于要拍广告了。”终于接到广告了。珍娜，我很喜欢你和泰德·丹森拍的那支广告。我觉得可爱透顶了。我拍过一大堆广告。我拍过别克（Buick）的广告。
Oh, I did a Lay's Lestra. Remember the potato chips? Yeah. Did you get anal leakage? No. But that was on the bag. It said it caused anal leakage, but I ate those chips all day, guys, and I was totes fun.
哦，我拍过乐事力萃（Lay's Olean/Lestra）薯片的广告。还记得那种土豆片吗？对。你得肛门泄露症了吗？没有。但那袋子上面写着它会导致肛门泄露，不过我一整天都在吃那些薯片，大伙儿，我过得可开心了。
Well, there you go. That's the best commercial ever. I did a Nordstrom's commercial. I actually found my old sizzle reel. You guys, when you're out here as a commercial actor, you would put all your commercials on one video to send out to people like a visual resume, and I found it, Jenna. That's amazing. I might have to put it in Office Ladies.
好吧，那就对了。那是史上最棒的广告。我拍过诺德斯特龙（Nordstrom's）的广告。我其实找到了我以前的试镜短片集锦。大伙儿，当你作为广告演员在这一行混的时候，你会把所有的广告剪辑到一个视频里发给别人，就像一份视觉简历一样，我把它找出来了，珍娜。太惊艳了。我可能得把它放进《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）里。
We should put our early commercials in there. All I have is me blurry in the background of a telephone commercial, the Jurassic Park ride. I'll put my Lay's Lestra spot, and you put your Jurassic Park ride. We'll put it in the stories. I don't even know if I can find it anymore. I'll look for it. I think they took it down off YouTube.
我们应该把我们早期的广告放进去。我所有的只有我在电话广告背景里模糊的身影，还有侏罗纪公园游乐设施的广告。我会放我的乐事力萃广告，你放你的侏罗纪公园游乐设施广告。我们把它发到动态里。我甚至不知道我还能不能找到它了。我找找看吧。我觉得他们已经把它从YouTube上撤下了。
That's too bad. Those would be too cute ones that we could put in. I have another fan question, Angela, from Ashley Snell, who would like to know, has Sue Grafton ever held a book signing at the Steamtown Mall? Ashley, I looked it up, and from what I could find, no. She is a real author. She is a New York Times best-selling author, actually. She is best known for writing a series of mystery novels starring a character named
太遗憾了。那些都是我们可以放进去的超可爱素材。安吉拉，我还有另一个来自阿什利·斯内尔（Ashley Snell）的粉丝提问，她想知道苏·格拉夫顿是否曾在蒸汽镇购物中心举办过签书会？阿什利，我查过了，根据我能找到的资料，没有。她是一位真正的作家。事实上，她是一位《纽约时报》畅销书作家。她最著名的作品是写了一系列以一个叫
Kinsey Milhoney. Kinsey. Milhoney. Kinsey. And it's spelled exactly like my last name, it's K-I-N-S-E-Y. Isn't that crazy? Yeah. I couldn't believe it.
金西·米尔霍尼（Kinsey Millhone）的角色为主角的推理小说。金西。米尔霍尼。金西。而且它的拼写和我的姓氏完全一样，是 K-I-N-S-E-Y。是不是很疯狂？对。我简直不敢相信。
It's the Alphabet Mystery Series. Kinsey Milhoney was a former police officer turned private investigator. Hmm. Jenna, should I play Kinsey Milhoney? You should definitely look into this. I have a little bit of extra trivia. This is not the first time that there is a Sue Grafton reference on the office. Back on The Fire, which was also written by BJ Novak, Michael confuses Stanley Kaplan,
那是字母表推理小说系列（Alphabet Mystery Series）。金西·米尔霍尼曾是一名女警，后来转行成了私人侦探。嗯。珍娜，我是不是应该去演金西·米尔霍尼？你绝对应该考虑一下这个。我还有一个额外的冷知识。这并不是《办公室》里第一次出现苏·格拉夫顿的梗。早在《火灾》（The Fire）那一集里——那一集也是由BJ·诺瓦克编剧的——迈克尔把斯坦利·卡普兰（Stanley Kaplan）——
who is the founder of a company that makes test prep materials with Sue Grafton. Now, I texted BJ about this because I was thinking, does BJ have a connection to Sue Grafton? BJ's father was a famous writer. I thought maybe his family knew Sue Grafton, but BJ said no, he just thought it was a really funny reference. There you go. All right, we have got to talk about this fantastic jingle that Daryl has written for
一家制作考试备考资料的公司的创始人——和苏·格拉夫顿搞混了。现在，我为这事儿给BJ发了短信，因为我在想，难道BJ和苏·格拉夫顿有什么渊源吗？BJ的父亲是一位著名的作家。我以为也许他的家人认识苏·格拉夫顿，但BJ说没有，他只是觉得这是一个非常搞笑的梗。原来如此。好了，我们必须得聊聊达里尔为广告写的那首绝妙的广告歌。
the commercial. Yes. Back by the break room, we have Daryl on keyboard, surrounded by Andy, Kevin, Creed, and Kelly, all singing this song that's meant to be in Michael's commercial. Michael comes up, he doesn't care for it. He was really hoping they were going to write a rap. Yeah. Daryl's like, what's a rap?
没错。在休息室旁边，达里尔在弹键盘，安迪、凯文、克里德和凯利围在他身边，大家都在唱这首歌，这首歌本来是打算用在迈克尔的广告里的。迈克尔走过来，他根本看不上。他其实是希望他们能写一首说唱。对。达里尔就说：“说唱是什么？”
And Michael's like, oh, Daryl, I'm going to make you a mix. And Daryl's like, yeah, I am. Looking forward. Yeah. We had a fan question from Kaylee Adkins, Winston F., Rob Holland, Alyssa Patterson, and Matthew Krule, and many others who wanted to know who wrote this jingle. Ooh, we have some good trivia about that, don't we? Yes.
然后迈克尔说：“哦，达里尔，我要给你做个混音带。”达里尔就说：“行啊，我等着。”很期待。对。我们收到了来自凯利·阿德金斯（Kaylee Adkins）、温斯顿·F（Winston F.）、罗伯·霍兰（Rob Holland）、阿丽莎·帕特森（Alyssa Patterson）、马修·克鲁尔（Matthew Krule）以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道这首广告歌是谁写的。噢，关于这个我们有些很棒的冷知识，对吧？是的。
The jingle in this scene was written by BJ Novak's brother, Jesse Novak, who is a professional composer. He's also done compositions for Bojack Horseman and the Mindy Project. He wrote this jingle. How fun is that? They kept it in the family. It's so great. Well, Jenna, now Jim overhears Andy telling Dwight he has an update for him for Operation
这个场景里的广告歌是由BJ·诺瓦克的弟弟杰西·诺瓦克（Jesse Novak）写的，他是一位专业作曲家。他还为《马男波杰克》（Bojack Horseman）和《明迪烦事多》（The Mindy Project）做过曲。这首广告歌就是他写的。是不是很有趣？他们把肥水不流外人田贯彻到底了。太棒了。好吧，珍娜，现在吉姆无意中听到安迪告诉德怀特他有“坠落天使行动”（Operation
Fallen Angel. And Jim is worried about Dwight and goes over to Pam, you know, going to share with her about his second life like, dude. Yes. Jim has created his own second life avatar because he's worried about Dwight. Yes. And he shows Pam, look at how bad it is. I'm going to take you into second life.
Fallen Angel）的最新进展。吉姆很为德怀特担心，于是走到帕姆身边，你知道的，准备跟她分享他关于自己第二人生（Second Life）的事，就像老兄一样。是的。吉姆为了德怀特，创建了自己的第二人生化身。是的。他向帕姆展示，看情况有多糟。我要带你进入第二人生。
Dwight has created second second life so that he can disconnect even more from reality. And this is when we find out a lot of things about Jim. About Jim. About Philly Jim. Yes. Jim's avatar has a guitar slung on his back. Remember, the only indication we've ever seen of Jim and guitar is that lone guitar in his room during email surveillance, but we never see him play guitar.
德怀特创建了第二个第二人生，这样他就能跟现实世界更加脱节。而就在这时，我们发现了许多关于吉姆的事情。关于吉姆的。关于费城吉姆的。是的。吉姆的化身背上斜挎着一把吉他。记住，我们唯一见过吉姆和吉他的迹象，就是“电子邮件监视”那一集里他房间里的那把孤零零的吉他，但我们从来没见过他弹吉他。
Clearly, Jim wishes he had learned to play that guitar. It's part of his second life avatar. Yeah, I guess it just sits in the corner of his room and is collecting dust. And even Pam is like, what? I didn't know you played guitar. Yeah. We had a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Maria Sosa, Keanna Raeber, Autumn Baker, Natalie H, and Delissa Alonis, who said, we find out
很显然，吉姆希望自己学会了弹那把吉他。那是他第二人生化身的一部分。对啊，我猜它就靠在房间角落里落灰呢。连帕姆都说：“什么？我不知道你还会弹吉他。”对。我们有很多关于这个的粉丝提问，安吉拉。玛丽亚·索萨（Maria Sosa）、基安娜·雷伯（Keanna Raeber）、奥秋姆·贝克（Autumn Baker）、娜塔莉·H（Natalie H）和德莉莎·阿洛尼斯（Delissa Alonis），他们说，我们发现
that Jim's second life avatar is a sports writer in Philly. Was his avatar's job the inspiration for Jim's season nine job? Was this planned? I mean, no. Right, Jenna? Is it just by chance? Here's what I think. I think this moment happened in this episode and it went into the show Bible, this little
吉姆的第二人生化身是费城的一名体育记者。他化身的工作是吉姆在第九季里那份工作的灵感来源吗？这是早就计划好的吗？我是说，没有吧。对吧，珍娜？这只是巧合吗？我是这么想的。我觉得这一幕发生在这集里，然后这个小小的桥段被写进了剧集宝典（Show Bible）里，对吧？然后后来到了要写第九季的时候，你知道的，那正是我拿到剧集宝典副本的时候，约翰也是。没错，因为你们俩是制作人，现在我想起来了，你们参与了诸如推销故事创意之类的事情。是的，约翰提出了这样一个构思：吉姆去费城发展并做这份体育工作。所以我没有向他核对过，但我不得不想象，也许——我只是在猜测。剧集宝典里有那个小小的时刻，他就顺着这个思路写下去了，但这确实是他的点子。
bit of business, right? And then later, when it came time to write season nine, you know, that's when I got my copy of the show Bible and so did John. That's right, because you guys were producers and now I remember you were part of like pitching like story ideas and stuff. Yes, and John pitched the idea that Jim would go off to Philly and have this sports job. So I didn't check with him, but I have to imagine that maybe I'm speculating. There was that little moment in the show Bible and he ran with it, but that was his pitch.
我们拍这一幕的时候它还没关联起来，但我觉得事情可能就是这样发生的。对，我觉得费城吉姆的种子当时就已经种下了。费城吉姆。还有一件疯狂的事。你后面会讲到，但我现在就先提出来。当他真的搬去费城时，他的公寓里确实有一把电吉他。我不知道他后来有没有学会弹吉他，但费城吉姆和他的吉他，他们
It was not connected in this moment when we shot it, but that's how I think it might have happened. Yeah, I think the seed had been planted for Philly Jim. Philly Jim. And here's something crazy. You'll get to it, but I'll bring it up here. When he does move to Philly, there's an electric guitar in his apartment. I don't know if he ever learns to play the guitar, but Philly Jim and his guitar, they
确实再次出现了。我的意思是，这一切都是有联系的，大伙儿。我确信。现在到了12分52秒，大伙儿，达里尔和他的团队正在继续排练。他们换了一首新主题曲，因为，你知道的，迈克尔给他们提了意见，对吧？所以现在他们写了一首新歌，你猜是谁写了这个版本？告诉我们，安吉。克雷格·鲁滨逊（Craig Robinson）。
do show up again. I mean, it was all connected, you guys. I'm convinced. Now at 12 minutes, 52 seconds, you guys, Darrell and his team are continuing to rehearse. They've got a new theme song because, you know, Michael gave them notes, right? So now they've written a new song and guess who wrote this version? Tell us, Ange. Craig Robinson.
是的。当然，我们都知道克雷格是个了不起的音乐家。哦，对，克雷格太棒了。他喜欢巡演什么的。他太棒了。在DVD花絮评论中，他们分享说，编剧室里曾有过一场激烈的辩论，争论他们到底该用哪首广告歌，最后他们觉得——当时意见分歧。他们两个都爱不释手，所以他们想出了一个办法，把两首歌都放进了这一集里，我觉得
Yes. And of course we knew that Craig was an amazing musician. Oh yeah, Craig is fantastic. He liked tours and everything. He's great. In the DVD commentary, they shared that there was a heated debate in the writer's room about which jingle they should use and they ultimately were like, wait, the room was divided. They loved them both, so they found a way to have them both in the episode, which I
这太棒了。太有趣了。对，BJ告诉我这很酷，因为它奠定了这样一个概念：迈克尔真的有强迫症，他一直逼着他们写新版本的歌。这一场戏里有一句迈克尔的台词我特别喜欢。他说：“我讨厌它。我不是讨厌它。我只是根本不喜欢它。”
thought was great. So fun. Yeah, BJ told me it was cool because it set up this idea that Michael was really obsessive and he kept making them write new versions of the song. There's a line from this scene that I love from Michael. He says, I hate it. I don't hate it. I just don't like it at all.
“太糟糕了。”我太喜欢这句台词了。关于评论音轨里克雷格提到的另一件事，我想跟你们分享的是，他当时只有一个小时的时间跟那些家伙排练，他说他们立刻就上手了，一下子就渐入佳境。除了可能有一个瞬间，我们收到了粉丝捕捉到的彩蛋。瑞奇（Rachel）和杰里米（Jeremy）写信来说，在13分15秒时，埃德开始唱歌的时间不对，然后他差点笑场，这简直太棒了。
It's terrible. I love that line so much. One other thing I want to share with you that Craig talks about on the commentary is that he only had an hour to rehearse with those guys and he said they got it right away, right away it just fell into place. Except for maybe one moment, we had a fan catch. Rachel and Jeremy wrote in to say at 13 minutes, 15 seconds, Ed starts to sing at the wrong time and then he almost breaks, it's the best.
姑娘们，我们去停车场吧。迈克尔对大家的耐心真的快要耗尽了。对。你知道的，这是一场关键的戏。如果他们搞砸了，整件事就会泡汤。对。安迪穿着某种跑步装备。他们没走多远，因为菲利斯从商场回来了。
Lady, let's move to the parking lot. Michael is really losing his patience with people. Yeah. It was, you know, this is a pivotal scene. If they don't get it, the whole thing will fall apart. Yeah. Andy is dressed in some sort of running gear. They don't get very far because Phyllis comes back from the mall.
女士们，我们去停车场吧。迈克尔真的对大家失去耐心了。是的。你知道，这是个关键场景。如果他们搞砸了，整场戏就全毁了。是的。安迪穿着某种跑步装备。他们没走多远，因为菲利丝从商场回来了。
She is sobbing. She is so gutted. She is gutted. She got kicked out of the mall in front of her friends. All of her friends, I guess, love Sue Grafton. They were all there for autographs. If Phyllis just wouldn't take no for an answer because Michael told her, don't take no for an answer, get Sue Grafton here and she kept bugging her and they kicked her out.
在这场戏的最后，有一个非常精彩的小包袱：凯文拿出一截胶带递给菲利斯，代替纸巾。我们收到了关于这个的来信，安吉拉，来自温斯顿·F和德利娜·德拉诺（Delina Delano）。他们想知道这个桥段是即兴发挥的还是剧本里写好的。为此我给布赖恩发了短信。因为我没有第四季的剧本。我猜是即兴发挥的。这非常像是布赖恩会即兴做出来的事。
At the very end of the scene, there is a great little tag where Kevin offers Phyllis a piece of tape in lieu of a tissue. We got some mail about it, Angela from Winston F and Delina Delano. They wanted to know if this bit was improvised or scripted. I texted Brian about it. Because I don't have the scripts for season four. I'm going to guess it was improvised. That seems very much like something Brian would improvise.
你猜对了。他告诉我，原本这场戏的结尾是镜头停留在菲利斯哭泣的特写上，而他其实和凯特站在稍微靠后一点的背景里。他们当时还在排练那个跑步的小场景。但他在最后想出了一个主意，走过去递给她一截胶带当纸巾。好吧，大家都超喜欢。所以他们下次拍这场戏时，真的把他稍微往前拉到前景里，并给了史蒂夫一句台词：“谁给她拿张纸巾。”
You are correct. He told me that originally the scene had ended with the camera just lingering on Phyllis crying and he was actually placed a little further in the background with Kate. They were still kind of working on the little running scene. But he had the idea at the end to walk up and offer her a piece of tape as a tissue. Well they loved it. So the next time they did the scene, they actually pulled him a little bit more into the foreground and they gave Steve the line, someone give her a tissue.
然后他撕下一截胶带，这就成了这场戏的笑点收尾。太棒了。简直完美。这真是个绝佳的例子，说明我们的即兴发挥是如何融入一场戏的。我们会演出来，如果他们喜欢，就会说：“好吧，那我们把你们拉进这个情节里，用这种方式来创造一个有趣的收尾或精彩的瞬间。”我还想指出的是，我觉得我能看到菲利斯快要笑场了。她看起来简直就像是要笑出来一样。
And then he tore off the piece of tape and that became the button of the scene. It's so great. It's perfect. That's such a great example of how our improvisations would work into a scene. We would do them and then if they liked them, they would say, okay, well let's draw you into this in a way that that creates a fun button or creates a fun moment. I also want to point out, I think I can see Phyllis about to break. She looks like she is literally about to laugh.
我不知道该怎么说才不会显得怪异，但我特别喜欢菲利斯这个角色哭泣的时候。为什么？为什么会这么好笑？她太擅长演绎那些情绪节点了，我就是爱她。我也很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。珍娜，帕姆在她的办公桌前工作得好努力啊，14分49秒。
I don't know how to say this without it sounding weird, but I love every time the character of Phyllis is crying. Like why? Why is it so funny? She's just so good at playing those like emotional beats and I just love her. I love it too. I really love it. Jenna Pam is working so hard at her desk, 14 minutes, 49 seconds.
那个邓德米夫林的标志，她真的是把自己的心血都倾注在上面了。我很佩服她。我觉得这就是成功的秘诀。不管项目是大是小，不管你有没有拿到报酬，当你是一个苦苦挣扎的艺术家时，你必须把每个项目做到极致。她必须把这个当成是要拍进马丁·斯科塞斯（Martin Scorsese）电影里那样对待，而她也确实是这么做的，我觉得她完全正确。没错。
This Dunder Mifflin logo, she is just really putting her heart and soul into it. I admire her. I think this is the key to success. It doesn't matter how big or small the project, if you're getting paid or not getting paid, when you're a struggling artist, you have to give every project your all. She has to treat this as if it's going in a Martin Scorsese film and she is, and I think she's right on. Yes.
正因如此，她甚至不回家。吉姆说：“你要走了吗？”她说：“不，我要留下来。”我有个问题。这算不算他们住在一起的一个小暗示？很有意思。我以前从不觉得他们住在一起，但我认为他们正处于恋爱关系中的那个阶段——经常在彼此的住处过夜。
And so much so that she doesn't go home. Jim's like, are you coming? And she's like, no, I'm going to stay. I have a question. Is this a little hint that they're living together? Interesting. I never thought they were living together, but I think they're in that phase of their relationship where they're staying over at each other's places a lot.
就像他们就算住在一起也说得通，但我认为他们还没同居。好吧。好吧，可怜的吉姆现在只能和梅雷迪思一起坐车回家了。确实如此。然后，我们发现帕姆在办公室里过夜了。第二天一早，镜头以帕姆被吉姆的电话吵醒开场。他给她带了早餐。他给她带了早餐。
Like they might as well be living together, but I don't think they are yet. Okay. Well, poor Jim has to ride home now with Meredith. He does. And then Pam, we reveal, has slept in the office overnight. And then the next morning opens with Pam waking up to a phone call from Jim. He got her breakfast. He got her breakfast.
在花絮评论里，他们说编剧室里曾有过一场激烈的争论：他到底是给她带橙汁还是咖啡？我不记得桌上有这两样东西。只有一个杯子装着橙汁，还有看起来像是某种早餐的东西，可能是三明治。对。我猜是麦当劳买的，因为吉姆说他做了薯饼。对。但他们觉得橙汁比咖啡显得更甜蜜一些。
And in the commentary, they said there was a big debate in the writer's room about does he bring her orange juice or coffee? I don't remember seeing either on the desk. There's a cup of orange juice and what looks like some kind of breakfast, maybe sandwich. Yeah. I'm guessing it's from McDonald's because Jim says that create the hash browns. Yes. But they felt like orange juice was just a sweeter token than coffee.
他们就是这么决定的。但是任何细节都不放过，大伙儿。重点就在于，为了到底是买橙汁还是买咖啡，他们进行了一整场讨论。可见所有这些时刻都凝聚了多少心血。好吧，帕姆平时不怎么喝咖啡。她喝茶，所以我觉得橙汁是正确的选择。帕姆在访谈中解释说，她工作到凌晨2点45分，然后她必须在“留在办公室跟迈克尔和德怀特过夜”或者“冒险开车回家，却在方向盘上睡着并死于车祸烈火”之间做出抉择。
That's what they decided. But no detail went unturned, you guys. This is the point that there was a whole conversation about should there be orange juice or coffee. That's how much thought was put into all of these moments. Well, Pam does not regularly drink coffee. She drinks tea, so I think orange juice was the right choice. Pam explains in a talking head that she worked until 2.45 a.m. and then she had to decide between spending the night with Michael and Dwight in the office or risk driving home
她在做决定时累得趴在键盘上不省人事了。所以这就是我和杰森拍那个访谈时怎么也过不去的片段。我怎么也过不去最后那句台词。我累得趴在键盘上不省人事，因为中间有这么一个小停顿，而那个停顿会让我们对最后那句台词充满期待，从而忍不住笑场。这件事你们大家应该都知道。这些年来我发现——我想珍娜你也会同意我的看法——喜剧里的停顿往往比台词本身更能戳中你。
and falling asleep at the wheel and dying in a fiery car wreck. She passed out on her keyboard trying to decide. So this was the talking head with Jason that I could not get through. I could not get through that last line. I passed out on my keyboard trying to decide because there's this little pause and in that pause, the anticipation of that last line would make us laugh. This is something you guys should all know. I have found over the years, and I think, Jenna, you'll agree with me, it's the pauses
当史蒂夫在作为迈克尔说出什么荒谬的话之前停顿一下时，正是那三秒钟的停顿让我们所有人都笑翻在地。那就像是一个集体时刻，我们都知道接下来要发生什么，却又无法忍受。百分之百。我发现了一个穿帮点。好的。
in comedy that get you almost more than the line. When Steve would pause before saying something ridiculous as Michael, it was that three-second pause that would have us all on the floor. It was like this collective moment where we all knew what was coming and we couldn't bear it. A hundred percent. I have a catch. Okay.
在接下来的某一集里，剧情会揭晓帕姆其实戴眼镜。还记得吗，因为她不得不戴备用眼镜去上班。对。那是不是意味着帕姆带着隐形眼镜睡觉了？这样真的可以吗？我不戴隐形眼镜，但我认为这是不应该做的。我觉得那是绝对的大忌。我觉得那会让你的眼球变干之类的。
In an upcoming episode, it is going to be revealed that Pam wears glasses. Remember because she's going to have to wear her spare pair to work. Right. Does that mean that Pam just slept in her contacts? Can you do that? I don't wear contacts, but I think you're not supposed to do that. I think that's a big no-no. I think it dries your eyeballs out or something.
我是说，还有就像——帕姆难道不在办公桌里备一支牙刷和牙膏吗？我当时也有同感。最后，在我们离开这个小插曲之前，德怀特对那张沙发做了什么？他把它侧放着，然后把所有的垫子都拿掉了，自己睡在垫子底下。太诡异了。我觉得他当时冷，想做一个垫子毯子。我猜吧。
I mean, also like just Pam keep a toothbrush and toothpaste in her desk, I thought the same thing. And finally, before we move on from this little moment, what has Dwight done to the couch? He turned it on its side and then he has taken all the cushions off and he is sleeping under the cushions. It's so odd. I think he got cold and he was trying to make a cushion blanket. I guess.
非常奇怪。我觉得他以前这么干过。他对那张沙发有一套自己的系统。我们现在知道的是，安吉拉，可能德怀特、帕姆和迈克尔的口气都有点难闻，因为我无法想象他们任何人带了牙刷。没有。不过迈克尔也许有吧，我觉得迈克尔可能会在他的柜子里备一支。所以他口气清新，但我是说。
It's very strange. I feel like he's done it before. He has a system for that couch. What we know now, Angela, is probably that Dwight, Pam, and Michael all have really bad breath because I can't imagine any of them had toothbrushes. No. Maybe Michael, though, I feel like maybe Michael keeps one in his cabinet. So he's got fresh breath, but I mean.
我猜迈克尔那个柜子里有一整套换洗衣物，还有平角内裤、几双袜子。对。他有备无患。当我们走到休息室时，因为安迪有个好消息要告诉德怀特。不。坠落天使行动迎来了转折。我猜当他们在进行那种亲热时，安迪在亲吻她的耳垂，然后
My guess is Michael has a whole change of clothes in that cabinet and he's got some boxer shorts, pair of socks. Yeah. He's prepared. When we move into the break room, because Andy has some news for Dwight. No. Operation Fallen Angel turned a corner. I guess while they were doing their form of necking, he's kissing her ear lobe and
她说了“O-D”。德怀特的脸亮了。亮了。安迪以为这是因为他的名字“安迪”，但我们都知道真相。安迪，这也太牵强了吧。她怎么会单单挑出你名字里的一个字母呢？O-A。O-N。
she says O-D. Dwight's face lights up. Lights up. Andy thinks that this is because of his name, Andy, but we all know the truth. Andy, what a stretch. Why would she single out one letter of your name? O-A. O-N.
她放声痛哭。她心碎欲绝。她心碎欲绝。她在所有朋友面前被赶出了商场。我猜她所有的朋友都喜欢苏·格拉夫顿。他们都在那儿等签名。菲利斯就是不肯接受“不”这个答案，因为迈克尔告诉她：别接受“不”的回答，把苏·格拉夫顿弄来，结果她一直纠缠人家，然后他们就把她赶出来了。
O-D. O-Y. Yeah. But Dwight then has this very fun moment where he is rejoicing with Andy over Angela calling out O-D. There's hope, Dwight. I love the next scene. Michael sends the commercial to corporate.
O-D。O-Y。是的。但随后德怀特有一个非常有趣的时刻，他和安迪一起为安吉拉说出O-D而欢呼。希望还在，德怀特。我喜欢接下来的场景。迈克尔把广告发给了总公司。
He's like, they'll probably watch it right away. I know I would. Yeah. And he's like, I'm not going to call him. I'm not going to bug him. And then he calls up 10 seconds later. I know it's perfect. We've all been there.
他就像是在说，他们可能会马上看吧。我知道我会的。是的。然后他就像，我不给他们打电话。我不会去烦他们。结果他10秒钟后就打过去了。我知道，太完美了。我们都经历过。
Yeah. We've all sent somebody something we've written, something you've worked on, and then you just wait and wait. And then you do that thing in your head where you're like, oh my gosh, what if my email was down? Yeah. What if they never got it? Oh, I should call them.
是的。我们都把写的东西、你精心创作的东西发给别人，然后你就在那儿等啊等。接着你在脑子里开始胡思乱想，天哪，万一我的邮箱瘫痪了呢？是的。万一他们根本没收到呢？哦，我应该打个电话。
I should text them and just nudge them. Yeah. 10 days later, and this was a big deal, this kind of time jump we hadn't done in the show before. It's very strange. We had that little bit of an unwritten rule that the ideal episode happened over one day. Yeah. We didn't always keep to it, but for the most part, our episodes happened in one day.
我应该发个短信提醒他们一下。是的。10天后，这可是个大事，这种时间跨度在我们剧里以前从没出现过。这太奇怪了。我们之前有个不成文的小规定，一集理想的故事应该发生在一天之内。是的。虽然我们并不总是遵守，但基本上我们的一集就代表一天。
So this says 10 days later. It didn't bump me, Jenna. No. I was fine with it. And Michael is saying, well, welcome to the world premiere of the corporate crap fest. Yeah. They did not pick his commercial. They did not.
所以这里写着10天后。珍娜，这并没有让我觉得突兀。没有。我完全能接受。迈克尔在说，欢迎来到公司垃圾大秀的世界首映。是的。他们没有选中他的广告。根本没有。
The whole gang has gathered at Poor Richard's Pub to watch the corporate crap fest. Yeah. Yeah. They watch it. They're delighted. They are in the last five seconds. It's the same commercial as the Nashua branch, but this time it ends with everyone at Dunder Mifflin Scranton waving.
所有人聚集在穷理查酒吧观看公司垃圾大秀。是的。是的。他们看着。他们很高兴。到了最后五秒钟。广告内容和纳什华分公司的一样，但这次结尾变成了邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司的所有人在挥手。
On the roof. On the roof. I guess that was Michael's big creative contribution is we'll wave from the roof. Yeah. We won't be in the parking lot. We're going to go on the rooftop. Jenna, do you remember I wasn't there that day? No.
在屋顶上。在屋顶上。我猜迈克尔重大的创意贡献就是我们在屋顶上挥手。是的。我们不在停车场。我们要去屋顶上。珍娜，你记得我那天不在吗？没有。
I know. Mindy and I both were not there that day. We had to be superimposed in. We never went up on the roof. We just did a wave. They sort of cheated it in the parking lot. And then they did a little fancy editing and put us in the shot. That is crazy because I did look specifically to see if everyone was in there and you're
我知道。敏迪和我那天都不在。我们是后期合成进去的。我们从来没上过屋顶。我们只是挥了挥手。他们在停车场假装拍了一下。然后通过一些花哨的剪辑把我们放进了镜头里。太疯狂了，因为我还特意看了看是不是所有人都在里面，而你
there. But if you look closely and I screen grabbed it, Mindy and I are kind of awkwardly off to the side. Do you see the gap? That is crazy. That's like that crazy thing they do when someone has to play their own twin. Exactly. Well, you can see it at 18 minutes, 10 seconds.
就在里面。但如果你仔细看——我还截了图——敏迪和我尴尬地站在边上。你看到那个空隙了吗？太疯狂了。就像那种某人必须扮演自己双胞胎时的疯狂特效。没错。好吧，你可以在18分10秒的时候看到。
And I know why I couldn't be there that day. I can't remember why Mindy couldn't be there. But I had one of my first OBGYN appointments because I was pregnant. Lady, I was wondering if you were going to share that in this episode because I just want you to know I can see, I'm getting goosebumps, I can see your glow in this whole episode. Yes. I clocked it the minute I put this episode on. I was like, oh my gosh, this is the episode where Angela was pregnant.
我知道我当时为什么去不了。我不记得敏迪为什么去不了了。但我当时去做了第一次妇产科产检，因为我怀孕了。女士，我在想你是否会在这集里分享这个，因为我想让你知道我能看出来，我起鸡皮疙瘩了，我在这一整集里都能看到你的光彩。是的。我一打开这一集就注意到了。我就想，天哪，这就是安吉拉怀孕的那一集。
Yes. And I had this appointment and I guess I couldn't move it and, you know, Kent was really sweet. He was like, oh, it's fine, Angela. Well, don't worry about it. Go to your appointment. Yeah. There's a present in it. Well, I'll never forget, Angela, because you told me you were pregnant in my trailer
是的。我当时有个预约，我想我没办法改期，你知道，肯特人真的很好。他说，哦，没关系，安吉拉。好吧，别担心。去你的预约吧。是的。里面有个礼物。好吧，我永远不会忘记，安吉拉，因为你在我的拖车里告诉我你怀孕了
at work. Yes. This is one of my favorite moments of our whole friendship. We were in Genesis trailer having lunch as we often did and you were telling me a whole story. I think it was about your cat. Is that about your cat? Lady, I remember I was done with lunch.
在工作时。是的。这是我们整个友谊中最喜欢的时刻之一。我们在珍妮斯的拖车里吃午饭，就像我们经常做的那样，你当时在跟我讲一个完整的故事。我想那是关于你的猫的。那是关于你的猫吗？女士，我记得我午饭吃完了。
You were still eating and I was doing these little five pound weights, little bicep curls. Yes. You were telling me a whole story while lifting weights. You were very passionate. I'll never forget it because I go on and on and on and on. I'm pumping my arms and then I get finished and you say, well, I have some news. I'm pregnant and I just dropped the weights and I screamed and our AD came over to the trailer because I think they thought someone had had an accident.
你还在吃，而我在做这五个磅的小哑铃，做二头肌弯举。是的。你一边举重一边跟我讲整个故事。你当时非常热情。我永远不会忘记，因为我滔滔不绝地说个不停。我用力挥舞着手臂，然后我做完了，你说，嗯，我有个消息。我怀孕了，然后我直接把哑铃扔了，我尖叫起来，我们的副导演跑到了拖车旁，因为我想他们以为有人出事故了。
There was this huge thud followed by a scream. And then you said to me, Ang, why didn't you interrupt me? I'm just rambling on about nothing and you're sitting on this big piece of information. Why did you let me go on and on? And I said, well, I wanted to hear your story. My God. So funny. I was just so happy for you.
接着是一声巨响，然后是一声尖叫。然后你对我说，安吉，你为什么不打断我？我只是在胡说八道，而你却坐在这么大的一个秘密上。你为什么让我说个没完？我说，哦，我只想听你的故事。天哪。太搞笑了。我当时为你感到太高兴了。
I knew how much you wanted to be a mother and I could just, I'm tearing up right now thinking about it because you are such a good mother. You are a born nurturer and I was just so happy for you. I knew how much you wanted that, but yes, when I watched this episode, I knew right away. Oh, this is the one and I didn't know if you were going to share it or not. So I waited. Yes.
我知道你有多渴望成为一名母亲，现在想起来我甚至热泪盈眶，因为你真的是个好母亲。你天生就是个会照顾人的人，我当时为你感到由衷的高兴。我知道你有多想要这个，但是是的，当我看到这一集时，我一眼就认出来了。哦，这就是那个画面，我不知道你当时会不会把它分享出来。所以我等了等。是的。
I was never up on the roof, never, never in the whole series. Wow. I know. Your old hat at being up on the roof. Oh man. So Jim does a very sweet thing. He asked the bartender if he will play their commercial, the one that they all made together. He hands them the disc and Michael is so moved by this.
我从来没有上过屋顶，从来没有，整部剧里都没有。哇。我知道。你对上屋顶这种事可是老手了。哦天哪。所以吉姆做了一件非常贴心的事。他问调酒师是否愿意播放他们的广告，也就是他们大家一起制作的那支。他把光盘交给了他们，迈克尔对此感动不已。
Yeah. Well, you know, the bartender slash waiter guy was played by Drew Powell. You guys might recognize him from Gotham. He's a regular on Gotham. He also played Eddie Murdock from the Monk episode, Mr. Monk Can't See a Thing. And here's my crossover connection with Drew. Drew and I played husband and wife in a lifetime movie called Terror in the Woods. Oh, I remember this.
是的。嗯，你知道，那个扮演调酒师兼服务员小哥的是德鲁·鲍威尔。你们可能在《哥谭》里认出他。他是《哥谭》的常规演员。他还演过《神探阿蒙》那一集《神探阿蒙看不见》里的埃迪·默多克。这就是我和德鲁的缘分所在。德鲁和我在一部叫《林中恐吓》的终身频道电影里演过夫妻。哦，我记得这个。
Yes. We filmed it in Atlanta and so we hung out and spent some time together. And when I got back to LA, we realized our kids were at the same elementary school. You're kidding me. No. Our sons went to elementary school together and then I started seeing him at morning assembly meetings and all kinds of stuff. That's so crazy.
是的。我们在亚特兰大拍摄的，所以我们一起玩过，也花了一些时间在一起。等我回到洛杉矶后，我们发现我们的孩子在同一所小学。你在开玩笑吧。没有。我们的儿子们一起上小学，然后我开始在早晨的集会和各种活动中看到他。太疯狂了。
I know. What a small world. So everybody watches Michael's version of the commercial and it's so charming. Jason reacts really well to it and there was a decision to be made as to whether or not when we watch Michael's commercial, we were going to be kind of embarrassed and like, oh, Michael, or if we were all going to love it. And Jason talked about this. It was really important to him that they pick the sweeter ending.
我知道。世界真小。所以每个人都看了迈克尔版本的广告，它太迷人了。杰森对此反应非常好，当时面临一个决定，就是当我们看迈克尔的广告时，我们是会觉得有点尴尬，比如，哦，迈克尔，还是我们大家都会喜欢它。杰森谈到了这一点。他们选择更温馨的结局对他来说真的很重要。
Here's what he had to say. There was an opportunity for a tender ending and I got the sense that the writing staff of the office was hesitant to do too many of those, that there's this kind of traditional television episode where it's funny throughout, it has opportunity for satire. And then towards the end, you have some sort of tender denouement and that they didn't want to be doing this every time. But I really wanted that for this spot. I really wanted the episode to end in a bar where the cast is watching the commercial
他是这么说的。当时有一个迎来温馨结局的机会，我有一种感觉，办公室的编剧团队对于做太多这种类型的剧集有所顾忌，因为存在那种传统的电视剧集，它从头到尾都很好笑，有讽刺的空间。然后在快结束时，你会有某种温情的结局，他们不想每一次都这样做。但我真的很想在这个片段里加入这种感觉。我真的很希望这一集在酒吧结束，演员们在看广告
together and they bond over it. And there's something really lovely about people who come together to make something that was really important to me because that's an idea I know really well, like anyone who's ever done a high school play or made a high school video or done anything creative knows what it feels like when outsiders come together to make something. And no matter how it turns out, the collective process of creating something is just wonderful and bonds you and erases fights because you can't help it, but come together and make something.
聚在一起并因此建立了深厚的感情。人们聚在一起创作出某样东西，这其中有一种非常美妙的感觉，这对我来说真的很重要，因为那是一个我非常熟悉的想法，就像任何曾经排演过高中话剧、制作过高中视频或做过任何有创意的事情的人一样，都知道当局外人聚在一起创作东西时的感觉。不管结果如何，创造某事物的集体过程是如此奇妙，它能将你凝聚在一起，消除争端，因为你别无选择，只能聚在一起完成某项创作。
And that's what the end of that episode felt like. I remember everyone just standing in the bar watching the episode and we aired the episode. You know, we played back the actual thing. It was just so lovely. And I remember seeing a cut of the episode for the first time and again, watching an edit of the episode was much like directing it. These guys knew what they were doing.
这就是那一集结尾给人的感觉。我记得大家就站在酒吧里看着那一集，我们播出了那一集。你知道，我们回放了实际的东西。真的是太美妙了。我记得第一次看到这一集的剪辑版本，再次观看这一集的剪辑很像是在导演它。这些人知道他们在做什么。
You know, I don't think I had any notes. I just kind of watched an office episode that I happened to have a directing credit on and has a slightly emotional ending and I'm really proud and I'm really grateful that the writing staff was up for that at the end of the day because it makes me cherish the episode even more. I love it too. Oh my gosh. Yeah, I couldn't imagine it any other way.
你知道，我觉得我没有任何意见。我只是看了看我恰好挂名导演的一集办公室，它有着略带感伤的结局，我真的感到很骄傲，也很感激编剧团队最终能够接受这一点，因为这让我更加珍惜这一集。我也很喜欢。哦天哪。是的，我无法想象它还能有别的结局。
I mean, this was such a big collective project that everyone came together for. I feel like everyone in the office would have had some kind of personal interest in it and I'm so glad we were happy and reacted that way. I have a confession. What? The very beginning of the commercial, it starts with a woman's hand taking a piece of paper off of the copier. That is supposed to be me.
我的意思是，这是一个每个人都齐心协力的巨大集体项目。我觉得办公室里的每个人都会对它产生某种个人兴趣，我很高兴我们当时都很开心并做出了那样的反应。我有个坦白。什么？广告的最开始，是以一只女人的手从复印机上拿走一张纸开始的。那本该是我。
That's supposed to be Pam, but I wasn't there that day. I don't know why. I was not pregnant, everybody, for whatever reason. They put Pam's watch and Pam's sweater on someone else. I don't know. I kind of feel like it was one of our AEDs or one of our PAs, so that is not my hand at the top. I did not know that.
那本该是帕姆，但我那天不在场。我不知道为什么。各位，我当时并没有怀孕，不管出于什么原因。他们把帕姆的手表和帕姆的毛衣穿在别人身上了。我不知道。我总觉得那是我们的某个副导演或制片助理，所以那不是我的手。我之前都不知道这一点。
I am not in this either. One of the things Jason said in the commentary about it that I loved is that he said filming this really reminded him of home movies he would make with his dad. His dad is Ivan Reitman, an amazing director. Jason said when he was a kid, he had a little handheld camera, and he would make these videos like the paper airplane like that, all of that with his dad, and it really reminded him of that. That's, in fact, how they shot.
我也不在这个镜头里。杰森在评论中提到的一点我很喜欢，他说拍摄这个片段真的让他想起了他小时候和他爸爸一起拍的家庭录影带。他的爸爸是伊万·雷特曼，一位优秀的导演。杰森说他小时候有一个小型的便携摄像机，他会和爸爸一起制作像纸飞机那样的视频，所有这些，这真的让他想起了那些。事实上，他们就是这样拍摄的。
They shot with just a little handheld. It's funny you mentioned the paper airplane because we had a fan question from Grant Pickle, who said, how did you get the shot of the paper airplane? Well, guys, they just taped it to the front of this little handheld camera, and Jason talked about the inspiration behind that shot. Sam, will you play that clip? There was a shot that really became popular in the 90s, and you saw it in Sam Raimi films and John Woo films.
他们只是用了一个小型的便携摄像机拍摄。你提到纸飞机这事真搞笑，因为我们有一个来自格兰特·皮克尔的粉丝提问，他问，你们是怎么拍到纸飞机的镜头的？好吧，各位，他们只是把它粘在这个小型便携摄像机的正前方，杰森谈到了这个镜头背后的灵感。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？有一个镜头在90年代变得非常流行，你在山姆·雷米和吴宇森的电影里都能看到它。
I associate it with Evil Dead 2 and Army of Darkness, but also would have been popular in literally any John Woo film where you follow a bullet, where it looks like the camera is riding on the back of a bullet or an arrow or something like that. I could have just imagined Michael Scott seeing any one of these films, Mission Impossible 2, or Broken Arrow, or I don't know if Michael Scott watches the old Hong Kong films. But maybe he just saw Van Damme and Hard Target and was like, we need to do a camera attached to the paper airplane shot. And again, this is my favorite kind of thing.
我把它和《鬼玩人2》以及《黑暗军团》联系在一起，但它也可能流行于任何一首吴宇森电影中，即你跟随一颗子弹的视角，看起来就像摄像机骑在子弹或箭的背面或其他类似的东西上。我简直能想象迈克尔·斯科特看过其中任何一部电影，《碟中谍2》或《风语者》，或者我不知道迈克尔·斯科特是否看老香港电影。但也许他只是看到了尚格·云顿的《硬汉目标》，然后说，我们需要做一个把摄像机绑在纸飞机上的镜头。再次声明，这是我最喜欢的东西。
It would be kind of great to make an entire movie that way. I love how much thought went into this commercial. It's so perfect. Yeah. And at the end of this episode with a little tag, it's Andy's talking head. He's still trying to figure out the end of the Kit Kat jingle. He cannot figure it out. And he struggles with it throughout the whole episode.
用这种方式拍一整部电影感觉会挺棒的。我喜欢这则广告背后投入的这么多心思。它太完美了。是的。在这集的结尾有一个小彩蛋，是安迪的单人访谈。他还在试图弄明白奇巧巧克力广告歌的结尾。他怎么也想不出来。他在整集里都为这个苦恼。
Jenna, I wrote down every single guess that Andy made. Ed also mentions in the commentary that he must have improvised like 20 of these. And he didn't know until he watched the episode which ones made it in. Here's all of the wrong guesses Andy makes throughout this episode. Break me off a piece of that apple sauce, Chrysler car, football cream, lumber tar, Snickers bar, Grey Poupon, Claude Van Damme, Hair for Men, Poison Gas, Nutra Suite, and finally Fancy Feast. And he's convinced.
珍娜，我记下了安迪所有的猜测。艾德在评论中也提到他一定即兴发挥了大约20个这种词。直到他看了这一集，他才知道哪些被剪进去了。以下是安迪在这集中做出的所有错误猜测：掰我一小块苹果酱、克莱斯勒汽车、足球奶油、木材焦油、士力架、灰庞芥末、尚格·云顿、男士生发液、毒气、纽特糖，最后是风味盛宴猫粮。而且他深信不疑。
That's it. I did it. Nailed it. It's a cat food. Break me off a piece of that Fancy Feast. So good. Before we go, we have a final message from Jason. You know, my daughter, Josie, is 14 and she was a baby when I directed The Office.
就是这个。我做到了。完美命中。那是猫粮。掰我一小块风味盛宴。太棒了。在我们结束之前，我们有杰森的最后一段话。你知道，我的女儿乔西14岁了，我导演《办公室》的时候她还是个婴儿。
And to this day, she has only seen one movie I've directed. In fact, up until recently, she hadn't seen any film I'd ever directed and the only thing she had ever seen that I had directed was The Office, of which she is a super fan. And that made her overwhelmingly proud of me and made me very grateful that I had directed The Office. Because it put me in such high esteem of my child. But just to say thank you, it really is a privilege to be part of the history of that show.
直到今天，她只看过我导演的一部电影。事实上，直到最近，她都没看过我导演过的任何电影，她唯一看过的我导演的作品就是《办公室》，而且她是这部剧的超级粉丝。这让她为我感到无比骄傲，也让我非常感激我曾执导过《办公室》。因为它让我在我孩子心中赢得了崇高的威望。但我想说的是谢谢，能成为那部剧历史的一部分真的是一种特权。
Every once in a while, it'll pop up in a way. Certainly when I'm doing interviews, it's one of the questions that always comes up. What was it like to direct The Office? Because it's kind of like, you know, there's only so many people who have walked on the moon and there's only so many people who have directed The Office and I get to be one of those people. I've directed two episodes, in fact, and it's something that I carry really proudly. Because you know, I didn't create that thing, I just got to be a guest.
每隔一段时间，它就会以某种方式出现。当然，当我接受采访时，这总是会被问到的问题之一。导演《办公室》是什么感觉？因为这有点像，你知道的，去过月球的人只有那么多，导演过《办公室》的人也只有那么多，而我很荣幸能成为其中之一。事实上我导演了两集，这是一件让我引以为傲的事情。因为你知道，我并没有创造那个东西，我只是有幸成为一个客串。
You know, there's this presumption that you need to be angry to do comedy and being at The Office proves that concept wrong because it was a group of some of the loveliest and funniest human beings I've ever met. So sweet. So sweet. And Josie, we're so glad we helped make your dad cool. Yeah! There you go.
你知道，有一种假设认为拍喜剧你需要表现得很愤怒，而参与《办公室》证明了这个概念是错的，因为那是由于一群我见过的最可爱、最搞笑的人组成的。太贴心了。太甜了。乔西，我们很高兴我们帮你让你爸爸变得很酷。耶！就是这样。
Guys, thank you so much again for sending in your questions and Jason, thanks for sending in all those clips. And we will be here next week talking about Branch Wars. It's another hidden gem. I think we're going to have a few hidden gems in a row. I'm predicting. See you next week, everybody. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
各位，非常感谢你们再次发来提问，杰森，谢谢你发来所有的精彩片段。我们下周将在这里讨论《分部之战》。这是另一颗被埋没的明珠。我想我们接下来会连续看到几颗被埋没的明珠。我预测是这样的。大家下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉特顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月StitcherPremium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。